[Musique]
l'ordre du jour appelle une déclaration
du gouvernement suivi d'un débat en
application de l'article 50-1 de notre
Constitution
relative à la politique de l'immigration
je vais immédiatement donner la parole à
Madame Elisabeth borne première ministre
l'immigration est un sujet complexe il
nous conduit à parler de politique
publique mais aussi de notre histoire et
de notre conception de la nation
il est parfois l'objet de passion de
tension voire de fractures
et pourtant il est essentiel de pouvoir
en débattre sereinement
je sais en introduisant ce débat au
Sénat que nous partons sur des
fondements solides
la Haute Assemblée a toujours eu à cœur
de porter des débats d'idées et de
chercher des solutions communes
vous avez aussi je le sais et j'y
reviendrai travailler sur la question
migratoire sur ces implications et sur
les grands chantiers à mener
par les d'immigration c'est abordé bon
nombre de sujets c'est évoqué les causes
profondes des migrations la pauvreté le
dérèglement climatique et notre
indispensable coopération avec les pays
d'origine et de transit
c'est parler de nos frontières de nos
procédures et de notre droit
c'est relever le défi de l'intégration
dans quelques semaines le gouvernement
présentera un texte sur notre politique
migratoire les ministres reviendront
dans un instant sur ses principes
directeurs
comme je l'avais annoncé ce projet de
loi fait l'objet d'une vaste
concertation le ministre de l'Intérieur
la conduit avec l'appui de la secrétaire
d'État à la citoyenneté le ministre du
Travail s'y est également pleinement
engagé
le texte doit consolider les avancées de
la loi asile immigration et adapter
notre droit au défi actuel de la
question migratoire je l'ai dit à
l'Assemblée nationale et je le répète
devant vous nous n'avons qu'une boussole
l'efficacité nous porterons un texte
équilibré aux effets utiles et concrets
il me semblait donc important essentiel
même avant la finalisation du projet de
loi et comme je m'y étais engagé de
venir devant vous pour vous présenter
des faits des orientations et pour en
débattre
alors mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs commençons par les faits
d'abord oui il existe une immigration
légale je le dis car à entendre certains
ont l'oublierait cette immigration
légale ce sont des salariés qualifiés ou
encore les personnes que les Françaises
et les Français ont choisi d'épouser
j'entends souvent dire que le nombre de
titres délivrés à progresser c'est juste
la tendance ne date pas d'hier et elle
s'est vérifiée sous des majorités de
gauche comme de droite ainsi en 15 ans
le nombre de titres de séjour délivrés
et passé de façon progressive de 172
000 en 2007 à 271 000 en 2021
mais ne nous trompons pas sur les causes
de cette augmentation
contrairement aux caricatures
l'immigration familiale a baissé sur
cette période s'il y a eu une
augmentation c'est pour trois raisons
d'abord parce que notre enseignement
supérieur est attractif et que depuis
2017 le nombre d'étudiants que nous
accueillons à doubler c'est une bonne
nouvelle ces étudiants apprennent à
parler français à connaître notre pays
et le font rayonner dans le monde
deuxième raison de cette hausse le
nombre de salariés qualifiés et de
chercheurs que nous que nous accueillons
à augmenter en 15 ans et cela a
bénéficié à notre économie à nous
entreprises à notre innovation enfin
dernière raison de la hausse
l'augmentation modérée du nombre de
bénéficiaires de l'asile ce sont 30000
personnes menacées dans leur pays que
nous accueillons chaque année
c'est l'honneur de la France de leur
donner leur place c'est l'honneur de
notre pays d'avoir accueilli 3000
ressortissants afghan juste après la
chute de Kaboul l'an dernier c'est
l'honneur de la France d'avoir accueilli
108000 Ukrainiens depuis le 24 février
dernier sous le statut de la protection
temporaire au nom du gouvernement je
tiens à remercier Lovecraft les élus
locaux les associations et les
employeurs qui les accompagnent au
quotidien
bien sûr nous devons donner à toutes les
personnes arriver légalement les moyens
d'une intégration digne et complète
certaines difficultés existent encore
notamment en termes d'insertion
professionnelle j'y reviendrai voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
quels sont les faits concernant
l'immigration légale
mais le principal enjeu ça n'est pas
tant la situation de ce à qui nous avons
délivré un titre que celle des personnes
qui se maintiennent sur notre territoire
sans y avoir droit ces personnes ne sont
pas éligibles à l'asile il aura souvent
été explicitement refusé pourtant le
flux de demande augmente nettement ces
dernières années et celles et ceux à qui
nous n'accordons pas la protection
restent encore trop fréquemment sur
notre territoire
souvent victime de passeurs qui leur
promettent l'Eldorado et mettent en
danger leur vie la plupart d'entre eux
vivent dans la grande précarité sans
disposer du droit à travailler et
parfois sombre dans la délinquance
face à ce défi les amateurs de solutions
toutes faites sont nombreux on trouve
les partisans du yakafaucon qui
voudraient renvoyer d'un coup d'un seul
l'intégralité d'entre eux alors oui je
souhaite que le droit et nous frontières
soient respectés oui je souhaite des
éloignements rapides et efficaces des
personnes en situation irrégulière mais
non on ne peut pas prétendre que les
choses soient simples comme si nous
pouvions nous affranchir de
l'indispensable coopération des pays
d'origine et des règles de l'État de
droit de l'autre côté certains appellent
à des opérations de régularisation
massive je le dis aussi clairement il
n'en est pas question nous ne créerons
pas de telles précédents qui ne
régleraient pas les difficultés des
personnes concernées qui donneraient des
arguments au passeur et qui ne seraient
ni acceptées ni acceptable par les
Français
pour notre part nous voulons prendre le
sujet à bras le corps et proposer des
solutions utiles et efficaces je crois
que nous pouvons nous retrouver sur une
préoccupation commune évitez que des
étrangers restent durablement dans une
situation indéterminée qui ne serait ni
le droit au séjour ni l'éloignement
aussi nous voulons clarifier beaucoup
plus vite la situation des étrangers
arrivée sur notre sol d'une part nous
voulons accélérer les procédures
d'examen des demandes d'asile et du
droit au séjour pour lutter contre les
pratiques dilatoires et d'autre part une
fois la situation clarifiée nous
souhaitons éloigner plus rapidement ce
qui doivent l'être quant aux personnes
qui ont vocation à rester nous voulons
engager plutôt les actions pour réussir
leur intégration d'abord par la langue
et l'emploi
ces principes sont les grands axes de
travail du gouvernement ce sont des
objectifs qui je le crois peuvent
rassembler largement en particulier au
Sénat car je sais pouvoir trouver sur
ces bancs des partenaires pour pour
construire ce texte ensemble les
constats que vous avez formulés dans
votre rapport d'information et qui
faisait l'objet d'un large consensus
parmi les groupes au Sénat monsieur le
Président buffet nous les partageons le
projet de loi que présentera le
gouvernement reprendra ou s'inspirera de
bon nombre de vos propositions pour
celles qui relèvent du domaine
législatif nous en mettrons d'autres en
œuvre je pense à celle qui concerne
l'indispensable amélioration de
l'accueil en préfecture et les modalités
de recueil et de traitement des demandes
de titres de séjour j'y reviendrai et le
ministre de l'Intérieur également
je retiens cette volonté de travail
commun cette volonté de bâtir des
solutions au-delà des clivages et des
postures et c'est pourquoi comme pour la
loi d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur je vous
confirme que nous examinerons le futur
projet de loi d'abord au Sénat je
souhaite ainsi que nous puissions bâtir
une majorité solide sur ce texte on nous
appuyant notamment sur l'important
travail déjà réalisé par les sénateurs
sur ces sujets migratoires
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
comme l'a dit le président de la
République nous devons déployer une
action complète cohérente et efficace en
amont des flux migratoires et après
l'arrivée sur notre territoire nous
voulons d'abord prévenir les débarir
réguliers en contribuant grâce à notre
aide publique au développement à traiter
les causes profondes des migrations que
sont la pauvreté et de plus en plus les
effets du dérèglement climatique ensuite
nous devons mieux protéger nos
frontières pour y parvenir notre premier
levier d'action est européen pendant la
présidence française du Conseil de
l'Union européenne nous sommes parvenus
à plusieurs avancées autour du pacte sur
la migration et l'asile en particulier
pour rendre plus efficace les contrôles
à l'arrivée en Europe et pour renforcer
le mécanisme de solidarité pour les
états de première entrée dans le respect
du droit maritime
nous devons maintenant continuer nous
poussons pour un renforcement des moyens
de Frontex et pour une réforme de
l'espace Schengen nous voulons également
consolider le système d'Asie européen et
c'est aussi à l'échelle européenne que
nous lutterons plus efficacement contre
les réseaux de passeurs le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin le ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colonna et la secrétaire
d'État en charge de l'Europe Laurence
Boone sont pleinement mobilisés en ce
sens
le deuxième moyen d'action c'est au
niveau national en renforçant le
contrôle à nos frontières et en
accélérant les procédures en novembre
2020 le président de la République a
annoncé le doublement des effectifs à
nos frontières les résultats sont là 10
000 refus par mois ont été prononcés en
2021 contre 3000 début 2020 avant le
covid ensuite nous devons accélérer des
procédures d'examen des demandes d'asile
dans ce domaine des progrès ont été
réalisés dans le précédent quinquennat
les délais de l'OFPRA ont
considérablement diminué mais ceux des
procédures contentieux sont encore trop
longs au total le délai moyen de
traitement d'une demande d'asile est
encore de l'ordre d'un an nous devons
donc accélérer et viser un délai global
de 6 mois pour l'ensemble de la
procédure nous voulons notamment
réformer le contentieux des étrangers
pour le réduire et le simplifier nous
voulons passer de 12 procédures
contentieuses à 4 suivant en cela les
recommandations du Conseil d'État et du
rapport d'information du président
buffet le ministre de l'Intérieur il
reviendra et travaillent également avec
le ministre de la Justice
Eric Dupond-Moretti à une réforme de la
Cour nationale du droit d'asile enfin
nous voulons éloigner plus
systématiquement et plus efficacement
les personnes déboutées du droit d'asile
nous devons augmenter nos capacités en
centre de rétention administrative et
nous continuerons à agir dans nos
relations bilatérales avec les pays qui
refusent de réadmettre leur propre
ressortissants par ailleurs nous devons
être intrêtable avec les étrangers
délinquants même en situation régulière
s'engager dans la délinquance c'est se
placer en dehors de notre communauté
nationale c'est porter une atteinte
grave à notre pacte social et à nos
compatriotes c'est également nuire à
tous les étrangers qui vivent en France
et qui construisent paisiblement des
parcours d'intégration réussie dont on
ne parle pas
grâce à l'action déterminée du ministre
de l'Intérieur et des préfets plus de
3000 lettres étrangers hauteur de
troubles à l'ordre public ont été
éloignés en 2021 et 2022 enfin sous le
contrôle du juge et dans le respect de
nos engagements conventionnels des
mesures d'expulsion doivent désormais
pouvoir être prises contre les étrangers
quel que soit leur situation qui
commettent des infractions graves
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
le disais nous portons une vision
équilibrée si nous voulons que ceux qui
ne doivent pas rester part c'est aussi
pour pouvoir mieux intégrer ce que nous
accueillons cela passe d'abord par une
refonte en profondeur de l'accueil en
préfecture pour les démarches de
renouvellement des titres des étrangers
en situation régulière nous devons
éviter les pertes de droit notamment
d’emploi que peuvent connaître certaines
personnes fautes d'accès au guichet pour
les demandeurs d'asile nous devons aussi
continuer à renforcer nos capacités
d'hébergement en cinq ans nous les avons
déjà augmenté de plus de 36000 places
enfin le pivot de notre politique
d'intégration c'est le travail dans un
pays dont le taux de chômage est de 7,3%
nous devons d'abord chercher à pouvoir
les pour pouvoir les postes vacants en
proposant ses emplois à nos
ressortissants et aux personnes en
situation régulière le taux d'emploi des
immigrés en France et 9 points plus
faibles que celui de l'ensemble de la
population nous devons travailler à
réduire cet écart ensuite si les
employeurs ne sont pas parvenus à
trouver la main d'oeuvre dont ils ont
besoin ils peuvent la faire venir de
manière légale un employeur peut
toujours solliciter une autorisation de
travail si démontre qu'il n'a pas pu
pour voir le poste en déposant une offre
auprès de Pôle Emploi pour certains
métiers particulièrement en tension
l'employeur est même dispensé de cette
justification nous avons simplifié ces
dispositifs en 2019 pour mieux répondre
aux besoins enfin la question de la
régularisation
se poser pour des personnes en situation
irrégulière présente sur notre sol
depuis des années et qui travaille
depuis longtemps ce sujet mérite mieux
que des caricatures il ne s'agit en
aucun cas d'une régularisation massive
ni de laisser penser que la
régularisation serait la réponse aux
tensions sur le marché du travail il
s'agit de régulariser certaines
personnes qu'il contribuent depuis
longtemps à la richesse nationale mais
qui subissent parfois des conditions de
travail indignes et restent enfermés
dans un statut précaire le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft il reviendra
plus en détail enfin mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs s'intégrer c'est
parler la langue de la République alors
que nous proposons des cours de langue
dès l'arrivée sur le territoire nous
souhaitons qu'un niveau minimal de
Français soit désormais imposé pour
obtenir des titres de séjour de plus
d'un an
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
tracé devant vous les grands principes
de notre action une action fondée sur la
volonté d'équilibre et la recherche
d'efficacité d'abord agir sur les causes
profondes de l'immigration en lien avec
les pays d'origine et de transit
assurés ensuite le respect de nos
frontières et de notre droit par des
procédures plus rapides et des mesures
d'éloignement mieux appliquées et donnez
enfin à celles et ceux que nous
accueillons les moyens d'intégration
pleine entière et réussie car
l'intégration c'est bien la finalité de
toute politique migratoire autour de ces
principes je suis et je reste convaincu
que nous pouvons construire des réponses
ensemble je sais que le Sénat fidèle à
sa volonté de dialogue et d'actions il
prendra avec nous toute sa part je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole
à Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur des Outre-mer monsieur le
ministre
madame la Première ministre
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président
c'est un honneur après la première
ministre de pouvoir dire quelques mots
sur ce débat qui pense sympathique
migratoire de notre pays au moment où
comme l'annoncer madame la Première
ministre un texte sera déposé en premier
devant la Haute Assemblée un texte que
je porterai avec le ministre du Travail
en lien parfait avec monsieur le garde
des sceaux et qui prévoit finalement 4
sujets ou quatre thèmes que je voudrais
détailler après la première ministre le
premier celui de la fermeté le deuxième
celui de la simplification le troisième
celui de l'intégration et le quatrième
celui du travail je serai évidemment ce
quatrième thème évoqué par le ministre
du travail lui-même
celui de la fermeté parce que comme l'a
dit le président de la République
lui-même dans sa campagne électorale
comme la Haute Assemblée l'a déjà
réclamé comme la Premier ministre vient
de le signifier nous avons aujourd'hui
trop de difficultés à expulser des
personnes qui sont sur notre sol que
nous ne voulons plus et qui commettent
des actes délictuels graves ou des actes
criminels ou des personnes qui sont
fichées par nos services de
renseignement non pas par la
jurisprudence des tribunaux non pas par
les engagements constitutionnels ou
conventionnel d'autres pays mais par les
propres règles que nous nous sommes mis
nous-mêmes dans les années 2000 à
l'occasion sans doute d'un temps qui
n'était plus tout à fait celui que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui il s'agit de
mettre dans le texte de la République la
fin des réserves d'ordre public
c'est-à-dire la fin de la fin de la
double peine qui empêche le ministre de
l'Intérieur et les préfets d'expulser du
territoire national toute personne qui a
commis des actes graves condensation
défin pas les tribunaux à plus de 5 ans
de prison et qui relève souvent des
crimes des personnes qui s'en prennent
aux femmes ou aux enfants les personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique ou
par exemple les trafics de stupéfiants
aujourd'hui il y a 7 réserves d'ordre
public nous proposons de regarder qu'une
qui essaie de l'engagement international
que nous avons porté notamment vis-à-vis
des mineurs il s'agit en effet des
mineurs qui commettent des actes
délictuels ou criminel lorsqu'ils sont
mineurs puisque là il appartient
évidemment à l'autorité judiciaire de
suivre directement ces personnes mais
nous proposons de lever les autres
restrictions à l'expulsion de nos
concitoyens étrangers qui commettent ces
actes délictuels au criminels graves et
de pouvoir mettre ainsi dans la loi la
possibilité qu'elle préfère de présenter
à l'exclussion ces personnes évidemment
en respectant l'article 8 de la
Convention de sauvegarde des droits de
l'homme qui prévoit une sorte
d'équilibre entre la vie privée et
familiale et un endroit au séjour entre
la Sûreté nationale et la sécurité
publique et la vie et privée familiale
mais ce que nous disons nous c'est que
ce n'est pas à la loi de s'autocensurer
pour empêcher ses excursions 4000 par an
pourraient être prononcés et exécuté et
comme la rappeler même la première
ministre nous en sont à 3100 depuis 2
ans mais c'est bien au juge de confirmer
ou non cette équilibre entre la vie
privée et familiale et les impératifs de
la sécurité nationale ce que nous
proposerons au Parlement c'est de
supprimer donc ces réserves d'ordre
public et de copier-coller l'article 8
de la Convention européenne de
sauvegarde des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen le deuxième sujet sur lequel je
voudrais ici évoquer c'est celui de
l'augmentation des places de rétention
administrative dans le cas de la loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur le gouvernement accepté un
amendement du député
Eric Ciotti d'augmentation jusqu'à 3000
places de centre de rétention
administrative ce sont de la chaîne
administratifs sont nécessaires pour
pouvoir mieux expulser un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens étrangers qui
commettent des actes de vacances ou qui
sont fichés pour des services de
radicalisation nous connaissons
aujourd'hui une spécificité désormais
dans les centres de rétention
administrative puisque nous y mettons
désormais à 92%, c'est le chiffre de ce
matin des personnes qui ont un casier
judiciaire ou qui sont suivis par les
services de renseignement nous n'y
mettons plus les étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui sont sous le coup certes
d'une qtf mais qui ne présente pas de
danger pour nos concitoyens d'autres
formules sont à apprendre c'est-à-dire
l'assignation à résidence par exemple
depuis que je suis mise de l'intérieur
j'ai aussi demandé que progressivement
et c'est désormais plus le cas
aujourd'hui à l'exception du territoire
de Mayotte territoire bien spécifique
s'il en est nous pourrons reparler dans
le débat bien évidemment d'enfants dans
un centre de rétention administratif
et à la demande de Madame la première
ministre du président de la République
nous mettrons dans le texte de vous
présenterons l'interdiction de mettre
des mineurs dans des centres de
rétention administratifs dans les
prochaines années une fois que ce texte
sera voté la signation à résidence sera
évidemment la règle la spécificité du
centre de rétention administratif et
notamment son aspect carcéral mais aussi
les publics que nous y mettons désormais
c'est-à-dire des publics qui sont
dangereux pour nos concitoyens méritent
évidemment que nous puissions aller vers
ce genre de propositions à la fois d'une
augmentation considérable de place de
CRA nous en avons ne serait-ce que
l'année 2022 augmenté de 450 nombre de
places de craints éligibles et malgré
les contraintes du covid mais évidemment
correspondre à l'augmentation voulue par
le Parlement et peut-être dans quelques
jours promulguer par le Président de la
République de la loopnie tout en y
mettant pas des mineurs qui n'ont pas à
connaître ce type
de rétention le deuxième sujet après la
fermeté et je passerai évidemment sur
d'autres dispositifs qui seront contenus
dans la loi il s'agit des un grand acte
de simplification nous inspirons comme
un ministre directement du rapport du
sénateur buffet qui prévoit en effet de
simplifier de 12 à 4 le nombre de
procédures possibles pour nos
concitoyens qui viendraient contester
évidemment des actes administratifs pris
par des préfets de la République la
longueur de l'attente et des recours
suspensifs empêchent d'avoir une
politique d'immigration dignes de ce nom
digne de ce nom pour notre pays qui
n'arrive pas à faire exécuter
correctement les lois de la République
et lorsque les tribunaux au bout d'un an
d'un an et demi deux ans lui donne
raison les personnes sont souvent plus
expulsables parce que notamment ils ont
fait leur vie privée familiale ce sont
de la République et notamment eu par
exemple des enfants et qui rendent
inexpulsables de notre sol et en même
temps à ceux que nous disons oui
notamment dans le cadre de la demande
d'asile un an et demi deux ans fait
beaucoup trop long c'est beaucoup trop
long pour pouvoir s'intégrer et pour
pouvoir travailler pour pouvoir vivre
dans le pays qu'il est accueille parmi
les simplifications il y a une
simplification effectivement de la CNDA
que je garde des sources sans doute
reviendra en partie sur cette question
il s'agit pour nous de la
territorialiser pas garder une seule
scène des hame et de faire des CNDA il
s'agit pour nous de permettre le juge
unique alors nous entendons la demande
du Conseil d'État et de la CNDA de
garder une instance collégiale pour des
arrêts de principe je crois que le texte
de présenterons correspondra à la
demande du Conseil d'État mais que
l'immense majorité des décisions
puissent se prendre en juge unique afin
de pouvoir être beaucoup plus efficace
et beaucoup plus rapide il s'agit de
mettre en place sa visio-conférence par
exemple et il s'agit évidemment de
pouvoir simplifier le lien entre le
refus ce qui est le cas 70% de la
demande d'asile et le qtf puisque la
disposition que nous vous présenterons
il s'agira de correspondre à la à la
hausse de la campagne du président de la
République le refus
vaudra au qtf et le tribunal
administratif aura 15 jours pour pouvoir
juger
l'acte ainsi contesté aujourd'hui une
demande d'asile c'est entre 1 an et un
an et demi voire deux ans pour avoir une
réponse la loi colon a permis de passer
le travail de l'OFPRA de 9 mois à 5 mois
mais la scène des a malheureusement pour
les raisons que nous avons évoqué prend
un peu trop de temps en tout cas par
manque de moyens et par manque de
simplification l'idée c'est qu'on voit
de neuf mois la demande d'asile complète
de n'importe quel demandeur d'asile
puisse être jugé d'autres accès de
simplification évidemment lieu je devais
pas les détailler ici ils reprennent
largement le rapport du président du
fait je crois à l'unanimité de votre
assemblée le troisième sujet sur lequel
je voudrais m'appesantir encore les pour
les deux minutes qu'il me reste c'est
celui de l'intégration vous avez voté
dans la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur une
augmentation de 25% du budget
intégration plus de 100 millions d'euros
notamment de l'apprentissage du français
comme l'a dit la première ministre 25%
des étrangers réguliers sur notre sol
parlent très mal le français donc ont
beaucoup de mal à s'intégrer certes il y
a des cours de français obligatoires
mais ils ne sont pas sanctionnés par un
examen qui conditionnerait le titre de
séjour et ce que nous proposons c'est
que les titres de séjour soient
conditionnés à la réussite et non pas
simplement au passage de l'examen de
français et à conformément à ce qu'on
nous avons évoqué dans la loi dit des
principes de la République elle adhésion
des valeurs de la République et s'il n'y
a pas la réussite de cet examen de
français c'est quand même pour 270 000
personnes par an que cela serait
organisé et s'il n'y a pas de réussite à
l'examen sur les valeurs de la
République il ne peut pas y avoir de
titre de séjour comme les mêmes
l'immigration serait une immigration
familiale c'est évidemment très
important le ministre du Travail
reviendra également sur l'apprentissage
du français dans le cadre du travail des
obligations que nous pourrons imposer ça
demande quelque chose qui n'est pas
législatif mais ça demande quelque chose
qui relève évidemment du travail
réglementaire du travail d'organisation
du ministère de l'Intérieur une
révolution d'organisation des
préfectures qui doivent arrêter de
demander la vérification de titre de
séjour de gens qui sont depuis de
nombreuses années sur le sol national
qui travaille et qui n'ont aucun
judiciaire il faut que si titres là soit
automatique avec un devoir de rappel de
la part des fonctionnaires en cas de
difficultés ou en cas de casier
judiciaire évidemment de ces personnes
mais ça demande de concentrer
l'intégralité des agents de préfecture
et du travail des préfectures d'une part
sur les prix morts-vivants vérifier que
ces personnes parlent bien le français
veulent s'intégrer au accès à un métier
puisse faire vivre leur famille dans des
conditions acceptables d'intégration et
également d'expulsion puisque évidemment
il faut améliorer très largement les
exécutions de quitter le territoire
national et comme je l'ai dit le retrait
de titre de séjour aussi de toute
personne qui a quasi judiciaire
j'entaminerai par là mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs depuis 2001 et
depuis la circulaire que j'ai pris à la
demande du Président de la République 92
le titre de séjour ont été refusés ou
retirés pour des étrangers qui avaient
une difficulté avec les règles de la
République on va dire ça comme ça
évidemment désormais l'étape
supplémentaire c'est de pouvoir
s'assurer qu'ils aient quitté le
territoire national pour cela il faut
qu'ils moyens de la préfecture arrête
d'embêter administrativement ce qui ne
pose aucun problème à la République et
se concentre plus largement sur ceux qui
posent des prêts de la République je
crois que c'est ce que demande les
Français merci Monsieur ministre
d'intérieur
n'est la parole en monsieur Éric
Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre monsieur les ministres
monsieur président de la commission des
lois mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
comme la souhaité madame la Première
ministre le Sénat est aujourd'hui
réunis pour débattre d'un sujet
important un sujet extrêmement complexe
qui peut se résumer au fond d'une
question simple comment et sous quelles
conditions accueillir sur notre sol des
femmes et des hommes de nationalité
étrangères
l'immigration à l'évidence est un
phénomène qu'il faut voir de façon
globale et pragmatique
globale et la question de l'immigration
implique vous le savez de nombreux
périmètres ministériels
comme en témoigne d'ailleurs la présence
de plusieurs de mes collègues
pragmatiques car pour trouver des
solutions il faut se départir de tout
dogmatisme de toutes démagogie et bien
sûr de tout angélisme depuis longtemps
le ministère de la Justice travaille et
tous les autres ministères impliqués sur
la question de l'immigration et plus
particulièrement sur les procédures
administratives et pénales applicables
aux étrangers de quoi parlons-nous
exactement faut tout d'abord réfléchir à
la simplification du traitement du
contentieux des étrangers
je contentieux constitue l'activité
principale des tribunaux administratifs
et des courges administratives d'appel
comme le souligne avec acuité le rapport
Stal publié en 2020 sous l'égide du
Conseil d'État il faut avant tout
rechercher une plus grande efficacité
des mesures juridictionnelles cette
réflexion rejoint celle de l'excellent
rapport du président François Noël
buffet qui dresse
qui dresse un triple constat
droit des étrangers devenus illisibles
des procédures inefficaces et un manque
de moyens des services de l'État pour
les mettre en œuvre
fort de ce diagnostic partagé par toutes
les juridictions administratives par le
menteur
par nous le gouvernement va comme
l'indiquer mon collègue Gérald Darmanin
ouvrir prochainement le chantier de la
réforme du contentieux des étrangers il
y aura évidemment aucune question tabou
ainsi la réforme du contentieux de
l'asile devra également être mis à
l'ordre du jour
toutes ces questions sont en débat
aujourd'hui et le seront lors de
l'examen du projet de juin et je sais
bien sûr que vous aurez à coeur de bâtir
une procédure à la fois efficace
respectueuse de nos principes si je
devais en une phrase résumée le propos
la protection des droits et la
protection qu'offre le droit oui bien
sûr
l'instrumentalisation du droit et le
dilatoire non
le second axe de travail que je vous
propose concerne bien sûr la sphère
pénale
laissez-moi tout d'abord insister sur un
constat
il faut le faire lucidement oui bien sûr
il y a des étrangers délinquants oui il
y a des étrangers dans nos prisons de ce
point de vue d'ailleurs la moyenne
qui est la nôtre est une moyenne
européenne
mais disons-le l'écrasante l'écrasante
majorité
des personnes que nous accueillons sur
notre sol aime notre pays
et on respecte les lois
et je dis ça avec force parce qu'il ne
faut pas accepter me semble-t-il des
amalgames parfois faciles ou des
généralisations entre immigration et
délinquance et
pour autant monsieur les sénateurs
mesdames sénatrices je me gare de tout
angélisme et je souhaite que nous
puissions dans le cadre du projet de loi
permettre à notre droit pénal d'être
plus efficient les guerres des étrangers
qui ne respectent ni nos lois ni notre
pacte républicain pour y parvenir il
nous faut réfléchir à un élargissement
de la peine d'interdiction du territoire
français il s'agit aujourd'hui vous le
savez d'une peine complémentaire
prévue dans de nombreuses infractions
qui constituent les infractions les plus
graves crimes contre l'humanité
infraction terroriste atteinte
volontaire à la vie par exemple pourquoi
ne pas harmoniser les conditions
d'interdiction judiciaire du territoire
français avec celle des mesures
d'expulsion n'est-il pas légitime qu'un
juge correctionnel puisse protéger notre
territoire et nos concitoyens aussi bien
qu'un préfet qui décide d'une expulsion
pour un étranger délinquant
pourquoi également ne pas explorer
l'élargissement du champ infractionnel
de cette peine complémentaire avec bien
sûr toutes les précautions qui
s'imposent car cette élargissement ne
pourra avoir lieu sans que soit garantie
les grands principes de l'État de droit
auquel nous sommes tous particulièrement
attachés voilà ces pistes sont
sérieusement à l'étude c'est tout
l'enjeu des débats qui vous attendent
être ferme à l'égard des étrangers qui
s'affranchissent de nos règles tout en
garantissant à chaque femme à chaque
homme qui souhaite s'installer
régulièrement sur notre territoire un
examen individualisé de sa situation
personnelle et familiale mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs les Français
nous attendent ils nous regardent il est
dans notre responsabilité collective de
nous montrer à la hauteur de leurs
attentes bien légitimes
merci Monsieur garde des sceaux la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du somme
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre monsieur les ministres mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs une politique
d'intégration doit naturellement
envisager le travail comme un outil
essentiel pour cette intégration car
c'est à nos yeux le seul moyen durable
pour un étranger arrivant sur notre
territoire d'assurer sa subsistance il
faut aussi souligner rappeler que le
contexte professionnel facilite
grandement l'apprentissage de la langue
et l'apprentissage de la culture d'un
peuple par ailleurs la France comme de
nombreux autres pays a besoin de talents
étrangers cela ne signifie aucunement
que nous sommes déliés de notre
obligation de former et d'accompagner
nos compatriotes les résidences notre
territoire c'est notre priorité dans
notre marge dans le Pôle emploi mais
cela signifie aussi que nous devons
accompagner cette politique d'un recours
subsidiaire recrutement d'étrangers non
communautaire pour faire face à nos
besoins de compétences
en réalité nous le savons nous avons
déjà des procédures pour permettre
l'introduction de main d'oeuvre
étrangères et de talents venus de
l'étranger nous savons aussi délivrer
des titres de séjour à des personnes
présentes depuis plusieurs années sur le
territoire mais nous ne pouvons pas nous
soustraire plus longtemps à une analyse
du site de notre système et constater
qu'il est inefficace par plusieurs
aspects et injuste par d'autres
il n'est d'abord pas efficace car il ne
permet pas à de nombreux étrangers
arrivaient régulièrement sur notre
territoire de se former d'être
accompagné pour exercer un emploi cela
se voit dans les chiffres dans les
résultats de la politique de l'emploi au
premier trimestre 2022 le taux de
chômage des personnes étrangères était
de 13% contre 7 et demi pour l'ensemble
de la population et ce rapport ne varie
pas ni en fonction des crises ni en
fonction des périodes de croissance dans
le même temps nous enfermons aussi dans
l'illégalité des étrangers présents
depuis longtemps sur notre territoire et
travaillant notamment dans des secteurs
intentions ils sont pourtant essentiels
à la prospérité au développement de
notre pays ils sont le plus souvent
déclarés ils payent des impôts des
cotisations mais leur situation relève
parfois aussi d'une grande difficulté
d'une précarité et de la traite des
êtres humains l'absence de droit au
séjour les rend vulnérables et précaires
il arrive aussi que des employeurs peu
scrupuleux les oblige à travailler
parfois plusieurs semaines sans repos ou
encore être hébergé dans des conditions
indignes cela ne vaut évidemment pas
généralisation mais nous savons que cela
existe et que ces situations peuvent
vous présenter aussi progresser sur ce
sujet c'est progresser sur l'ensemble
des conditions de travail en supprimant
ces situations du pire et en revenant un
socle commun pour l'ensemble des
salariés
ce constat si il est partagé nos oblige
et nous devons sortir d'un système
perdant tout en même temps il nous un
combo si de faire davantage pour lutter
contre le travail légal et contre le
travail dissimuler ainsi des étrangers
présents depuis plusieurs années sur le
territoire travaillant depuis plusieurs
mois en France dans un métier en tension
sont en situation régulière irrégulière
et s'emporte de sortie il travaille il
s'intègre veulent s'intégrer sont
intégrés et ils demeure pourtant sans
droit au séjour ni au travail nous
souhaitons que ces étrangers puissent
obtenir un titre temporaire pour une
année renouvelable pour leur permettre
de travailler légalement dans les
secteurs dans les secteurs en contrant
les plus grandes tensions de main
d'oeuvre ils pourront ensuite s'insérer
dans un parcours plus classique toujours
par le travail et par la longue ça
s'appelle tout simplement l'intégration
et c'est ce que nous voulons promouvoir
comme nous l'avons indiqué avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur
je le dis au passage certains fake de
penser que nous allons ainsi favoriser
le travail des étrangers aurement du
travail des Français c'est faux par
construction les secteurs en question
ont besoin de main d'oeuvre ils en ont
déjà besoin des étrangers dont nous
parlons ne prennent le travail de
personnes ils occupent pas d'emploi sur
lequel il est bien difficile de recruter
et par ailleurs nous n'abandons
évidemment pas l'important est forte de
formation de l'ensemble des actifs et
cet objectif de plein emploi pour tous
de plus l'introduction de ce type de
séjour est aussi une demande forte de
nombreuses entreprises qui souhaitent
ainsi pouvoir régulariser accompagner la
régularisation de celles et ceux qui
travaillent pourraient dans ce même état
d'esprit nous avons d'ores et déjà
initier la révision de la liste
existante des métiers en tension elle
comporte quelques incongruités quelques
manques les métiers de la restauration
ils sont par exemple aujourd'hui peu
présents tout comme ceux de la propreté
or cette liste doit être plus en phase
avec la réalité des tensions de
recrutement
ensuite si nous devons regarder la
réalité en face pour ce qui concerne la
part des implants tensions occupés
aujourd'hui par des étrangers en
situation régulière ou irrégulière nous
devons aussi constater la faiblesse ou
plutôt la lenteur des sanctions
infligées le travail illégal est
constaté c'est une certitude la lutte
contre le travail illégal passera par
des sanctions plus facilement et plus
rapidement applicable il existe
aujourd'hui des fonctions pénales que
nous ne prévoyons pas de modifier elles
sont nécessaires au traitement des
situations les plus graves dès lors
qu'intensité la dégradation des
conditions de travail sont manifestes il
existe aussi des sanctions
administratives par exemple la
possibilité pour les préfets de fermer
l'établissement pour une durée maximale
de trois mois c'est une sanction lourde
que nous devons faciliter il nous faut
aussi une fonction administrative mais
calibrée pour être plus systématique
comme une amende de plusieurs milliers
d'euros pour un emploi illégal elle
n'aurait pas un caractère automatique
mais serait déployé en fonction
d'appréciation d'un certain nombre de
critères tels que les ressources les
charges mais aussi et peut-être surtout
l'intentionnalité le contexte et la
gravité
enfin je termine par là l'intégration
est une évidence le ministre de
l'Intérieur a dit se fait aussi par la
langue en cohérence avec cette exigence
de maîtrise de la langue nous
considérons que les employeurs doivent
aussi faciliter l'intégration leurs
salariés étrangers par la langue bien
des employeurs comptent sur la main
d'oeuvre étrangère pour faire tourner
leur entreprise il n'est donc pas normal
que les employeurs puissent contribuer à
la réussite de l'intégration de leur
salarié par la langue nous avons ouvert
un dialogue avec les partenaires sociaux
pouvoir comment par les opérateurs de
formation par le financement de la
formation continue par la possibilité de
libérer des heures sur le temps de
travail pour participer aux formations
nous pouvons mettre à contribution les
employeurs pour la formation en français
de leurs salariés étrangers nous
abordons ce débat sans naïveté en
voulant ne plus être les complices
passifs d'injustice existantes quant au
travail des étrangers sans naïveté ni
idéalisme mais avec du réalisme et la
volonté de protéger les travailleurs
comme les chefs d'entreprise qui n'ont
pas d'autres alternatives
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
nous allons aborder maintenant la suite
de nos débats et je vais donner la
parole aux orateurs des groupes tout
d'abord le président François Noël
buffet pour les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues il n'existe
pas le pays qui peut accueillir
l'ensemble des migrants économiques il
n'existe pas nous n'avons nous avons
besoin d'améliorer l'intégration dans la
République plus vite et mieux je ne veux
plus de femmes et d'hommes dans les rues
mais partout dès la première minute un
traitement administratif qui permet de
déterminer si on peut aller vers une
demande d'asile ou non et derrière une
vraie politique de reconduite aux
frontières
ces trois phrases ne sont pas les
miennes certains peut-être s'en
souviendront elles ont été prononcées il
y a déjà cinq ans par le Président de la
République lui-même à Orléans
on aurait pu être séduit il y a 5 ans
par ses propos qui semblaient annoncés
une grande ambition de moderniser et
dirais-je de pensées en fin dans sa
globalité notre politique migratoire
mais regardons les choses en face la
triste réalité c'est que notre politique
d'immigration d'asile et d'intégration
est aujourd'hui dans l'impasse je vous
conseille madame la Première ministre
que cette faillite trouve ses racines
dans les ermans d'un quinquennat de
Monsieur prendre le président Hollande
dont vous avez en partie hérité mais
force de constater que 5 ans après le
discours à Orléans le gouvernement n'a
pas pu se donner les moyens de redresser
totalement la barre
nous avons d'abord renoncer à la
maîtrise de l'immigration légale dont
chacun sait qu'elle nourrit pour partie
l'immigration irrégulière pour la seule
année 2021 et je reprends les chiffres
publiés en juin 2022 par le ministère de
l'Intérieur 270
000 premiers titres de séjour ont été
délivrés en France métropolitaine 100
000 de plus comme 2011 le stock de
titres valides à lui grimper de 1
million pour atteindre aujourd'hui 3
millions
l'ampleur de ces chiffres et de leur
évolution par d'elle-même certains sur
ces bancs soutiendront que l'immigration
est une chance pour les pays européens
sans doute mais à condition que cette
immigration soit un apport pour ce pays
et non une charge or comme le souligne
l'OCDE la contribution de l'immigration
à la société et l'économie d'un pays
quel qu'il soit et étroitement lié à son
niveau de qualification et le niveau de
qualification constaté en France et bien
moindre que chez nos voisins européens
quant à l'intégration elle ne peut
véritablement advenir qu'avec la
maîtrise de notre langue et le respect
des principes et des valeurs qui font
notre nation alors vous l'avez dit vous
même la semaine dernière monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur un quart des
étrangers en situation irrégulière
parlent ou écrivent très mal le français
côté immigration irrégulière nous allons
d'échec en échec avec d'abord une
maîtrise insuffisante de nos frontières
jeudi après ce qu'aujourd'hui presque
nos frontières européennes c'est un
euphémisme en 2006 sur ces mêmes bancs
le gouvernement de l'époque estimait le
nombre de clandestins présents sur le
territoire national entre 200 et 400 000
devant la commission des lois le 2
novembre dernier vous avez monsieur le
ministre évalué ce chiffre entre 600 000
et 900 000 il a donc multiplié par au
moins 2 en 15 ans et la potion est
encore plus amère s'agissant de
l'éloignement
le taux d'exécution des EQF se situe
selon les chiffres transmis par le
ministère un niveau familiique de 6,9%
au premier semestre 2022 on peut
toujours discuter la pertinence de ce
taux mais nous ne pouvons pas nous ne
pouvons que constater un indicateur
constant nous exécutions encore 22% nos
hôpitaux en 2012 3 fois plus
qu'aujourd'hui s'il y a lieu du côté de
l'asile ensuite nous sommes en s'il y a
mieux pardon du milieu du côté de
l'asile ensuite nous sommes encore loin
du compte avec un délai moyen d'examen
des demandes d'un peu plus de 330 au
jour aujourd'hui l'objectif de six mois
fiction 2017 et hors de portée à moyen
terme c'est de plus regrettable que nous
renouons avec les niveaux exceptionnels
des demandes connues avant la pandémie
nous devrions même dépasser l'année
prochaine le record de 2019 avec 135 000
demandes attendues
je n'adresses pas madame la Première
ministre ce tableau ni par malice ni par
fatalisme car se laisser aller à l'une
ou à l'autre ce serait renoncé à
chercher des solutions pour se réfugier
derrière des postures stériles ce serait
alimente ce serait alimenté chez nos
concitoyens des peurs qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être et ce serait surtout ouvrir la
porte en grand aux extrêmes vous l'avez
dit à l'Assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière madame la Première ministre si
nous voulons débattre sérieusement de la
politique migratoire nous devons nous
astreindre à un langage de vérité un
langage de vérité appuyé sur des données
partagées et indiscutables qui affirme
le constat lucide d'une immigration qui
n'est pas maîtrisée et d'une politique
publique qui a perdu tout son sens un
langage de vérité qui énonce clairement
les objectifs à atteindre et dénoncent
les postures l'immigration zéro est une
chimère l'accueil au fil de l'eau est
une folie
dans ce contexte ce qui nous fait
aujourd'hui cruellement défaut c'est en
réalité une réelle stratégie migratoire
car faute d'anticipation il faute de
volonté clairement exprimer nous ne
faisons que subir les soubresauts des
flux migratoires nous avons été dépassés
par l'intensité des flux en 2015 nous
sommes encore aujourd'hui avec la
reprise postokovide nous de vivre encore
un événement très particulier avec
l'océan de Viking notamment dans les
conditions dans lesquelles les
procédures ont été suivies tellement
complexes ce n'est pourtant pas un gros
mot que de dire que comme tout État
souverain c'est à nous qu'il revient de
dire qui nous accueillons sur notre
territoire et qu'il n'y a pas sa place
pour nous il y a trois principes le
premier une immigration régulière
choisie prioritairement économique et
qui trouvera d'autant plus sa place dans
notre société qui a y contribuera
pleinement
la deuxième de l'intransigence dans la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
et le troisième de l'efficacité dans
l'application de la procédure d'asile
voilà les trois piliers sur lesquels
doit reposer une semble-t-il notre
stratégie migratoire ces stratégie c'est
celle que défend le Sénat en tous les
cas sa majorité depuis de nombreuses
années c'était le sens des propositions
que nous avions portées de l'examen de
la loi Colomb en 2018 et qui ont été
pour partie balayer d'un revers de main
par l'exécutif à l'époque je constate
néanmoins avec satisfaction plus qu'une
infection de la part du gouvernement qui
envisage désormais de reprendre
plusieurs de nos propositions dans le
texte qui devrait venir devant le Sénat
premier lecture nous vous en remercions
au mois de mars prochain certaines
pistes du gouvernement peuvent être
intéressantes d'autres sont moins
acceptables mais j'y reviendrai
je me suis mise à l'intérieur vous
rappelez régulièrement vous êtes inspiré
pour la rédaction de votre texte du
rapport service de l'État immigration
retrouver sens et efficacité que votre
serviteur a rédigé au mois de mai
dernier c'est je dois le dire bien un
bon début mais pour éviter tout
malentendu et comme on n'est jamais
mieux servi que par soi-même je vais
vous faire des propositions assez
concrètes ancré dans les positions
constamment soutenues par le Sénat
depuis plus de 10 ans et qui vise à
doter la France d'une stratégie
migratoire réellement ambitieuse et
efficace même la première ministre vous
avez déploré la semaine dernière donc
voilà sur des nationales le manque de
proposition les nôtres vont être sur la
table permettez-moi de vous en présenter
quelques grandes lignes
la première priorité de retrouver notre
souveraineté en matière d'immigration
régulière décider qui l'on accueille sur
le territoire en assumant de prioriser
l'immigration économique pour mémoire
celles-ci représentée à peine 13% des
premiers titres le séjour délivré en
2021 c'est au Parlement qu'il revient de
fixer ses orientations annuelles avec
disons le franchement le débat sur des
quotas en tous les cas de grandes
orientations
recouvrez notre souveraineté c'est aussi
assumé de restreindre les voies d'accès
au séjour je pense à la procédure
étrangée malades pour laquelle il est
urgent de revenir aux critères de
l'absence de soins dans le pays
d'origine rien que pour 2021 nous avons
reçu 5000 demandes émanant des pays du
G20 qui disposent pourtant de système de
soins développés je pense aussi aux
regroupement familial pour lesquels nous
proposons de resserrer les critères
naturellement dans le respect du droit
européen
mais avoir une politique d'immigration
régulière cohérente c'est aussi mieux
traiter ce que nous acceptons sur notre
territoire je ne reviens pas sur les
situations ubuesque générées par les
difficultés au guichet des préfectures
pour obtenir ou renouveler un titre de
séjour la solution est pourtant là avec
une refonte des pratiques d'instructions
autour d'une logique dite 360 degrés que
votre gouvernement a expertisé ou
auprès de la préfecture d'Angers pardon
où l'on examinerait dès la première
demande et une fois pour toute
l'ensemble des motifs qui pourraient
fonder la délivrance d'un titre de
séjour est une très bonne démarche mieux
traiter les étrangers en situation
régulière demande également de muscler
notre dispositif d'intégration ou
proposer monsieur le ministre
d'augmenter le volume d'or de français
et c'est une bonne chose la contrepartie
c'est le renforcement des devoirs de
l'étranger vous avez repris la
proposition du Sénat de conditionner la
délivrance des titres de séjour de
longue durée à la réussite un examen de
langue fort bien nous estimons
nécessaires vous allez encore plus loin
et de la conditionner également à la
réussite d'un examen civique pour lequel
l'étranger démontrerait sa bonne
appréciation des valeurs de notre
histoire et de la culture de la
République de la France passez une
logique de moyens à une logique de
résultats ces jeux de croix la vraie
révolution pour le contrat d'intégration
républicaine
cette appropriation des valeurs
républicaines n'est pas négociable et
l'obtention d'un titre de séjour n'est
pas un blanc saint elle vient avec des
responsabilités à cet égard nous aurons
quelques difficultés à vous suivre dans
votre idée d'automaticité de
renouvellement de titre plural en tous
les cas à ce stade attendons de voir le
texte lui-même la deuxième priorité
c'est fluidifier le traitement des
demandes d'asile et de lutter plus
efficacement contre le détournement de
notre politique d'accueil il est crucial
de faciliter l'instruction des demandes
de protection internationale en
permettant notamment à l'OFPRA de
statuer plus rapidement sur les dossiers
les moins problématiques par exemple en
cas de retrait de la demande ou
d'abandon du lieu d'hébergement mais
aussi en lui imposant de refuser l'asile
en cas de menaces pour l'ordre public ce
faisant l'office pourra concentrer son
expertise sur les dossiers les plus
complexes je tiens à cet instant à cette
tribune à saluer le travail qui est fait
par l'OFPRA et la qualité des agents qui
travaillent au sein de cette de cette
institution enfin
nous nous devons de faire de la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière une
priorité nationale et d'agir enfin pour
la mise en œuvre des décisions
d'éloignement
prévenir l'immigration irrégulière c'est
d'abord assumer d'établir un rapport de
force avec les états d'origine le Sénat
avait voté en 2018 une disposition
autorisant les restrictions de visa à
l'égard des pays délivrant peu de
laisser passer consulaire le
gouvernement à l'époque ne l'avait pas
retenu ici est finalement résolu et là
encore cela produit quelques résultats
puisque le nombre de retours forcés vers
l'Algérie certes modeste en volume ont
malgré tout été multiplié par 16 en
moins d'un an
la montée en puissance de la lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine ne se
fera pas non plus sans réforme de l'aide
médicale d'État avec 400 000
bénéficiaires et un coût supérieur à 1
milliard d'euros celle-ci atteint des
sommets nous ne pouvons pas nous
satisfaire des derniers ajustements
paramétriques c'est une des réformes
structurelles dont nous avons besoin là
encore le Sénat défend de longue date
sont remplacement par une aide médicale
d'urgence centrée sur la prise en charge
des pathologies les plus graves l'ame
madame la Premier ministre se justifie
pour des raisons de santé publique mais
on ne peut obérer le fait qu'elle
constitue aussi parfois une incitation à
l'immigration irrégulière il en va de
même du projet des titres de séjour
métiers en tension qui est une opération
de régularisation finalement qui ne sait
pas dire son nom soyons clairs qu'est-ce
que l'attribution d'un titre de séjour à
une personne en situation irrégulière
sinon une régularisation la
problématique pourtant est réelle je
veux le dire à cette tribune la
situation est bien réelle nous ne
pouvons nier que nombre de métiers
parfois indispensables sont exercées en
majorité par des étrangers et nous
pouvons en débattre la solution pastel
pour autant par une régularisation
massive sans aucun ciblage au risque de
créer un nouvel appel d'air je pense que
non et nous savons tous que dans ces
conditions-là si cela devait être le cas
les affaires des filières criminelles
qui industrialisent le passage des
clandestins et joue avec leur vie se
formentaient immédiatement mais il
faudra il faudra des critères il faudra
des conditions il faudra préciser les
choses dans la loi parce que la
problématique est bien existante et
depuis le début je dis qu'il faut dire
les choses telles qu'elles sont pas
telles qu'on les aimerait ou tels que
vous les nirait c'est également le cas
de la réforme du contentieux nous le
savons tous le droit des étrangers est
une complexité qui frôle l'absurde il
suffit de voir le ceséda la taille qu'il
a pris c'est une charge pour les
magistrats chargés de l'appliquer une
source d'insécurité juridique pour les
justiciables et une aubaine le
clandestin cherchant à se soustraire à
l'éloignement le Gouvernement a souhaité
réduire à 4 le nombre de procédures
contentieuses nous proposons descendre
jusqu'à 3 mais la discussion se fera
naturellement nous sommes pas là pour
discuter de ces points de détails en
tous les cas mais madame la Première
ministre avant de terminer mon propos je
voudrais vous dire que je pense que ce
n'est pas en masquant les problèmes que
l'on va les oublier ce n'est pas en les
nommant que l'on va les aggraver mais
c'est certainement avec des propositions
concrètes qu'on arrivera à les résoudre
cela tombe bien n'en manquons pas celle
que je vous ai exposées et bien d'autres
feront part de nous serons dans nos
propositions il y a eu 21 lois
immigration en 30 ans ce qui fait à peu
près une tous les 16 mois je vous
propose que nous prenions l'engagement
de doter notre pays d'une vraie
stratégie en tous les cas pour notre
groupe nous y sommes prêts merci merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regroupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains je vais donner la parole
notre collègue Jean-Yves Leconte
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre messieurs les
ministres
l'asile est un droit c'est un engagement
conventionnel et c'est aussi une part de
notre identité constitutionnelle
l'immigration c'est autre chose c'est
une politique qui convient de mener en
respectant nos principes et en
respectant aussi au mieux les intérêts
de notre pays
avant 2018 jamais ces deux sujets
n'avaient été abordés dans les mêmes
lois parce que ce sont deux sujets
distincts malheureusement maintenant
nous devons les aborder ensemble nous
vous constater que la question de
l'immigration est un sujet sur Google
les Français semblent relativement
fermés entre guillemets lorsque la
question leur est posée d'une manière
globale mais par contre ils sont
fondamentalement ouverts et généreux dès
lors qu'ils font face à des situations
concrètes et ils sont attachés à notre
tradition d'accueil et d'asile rappelons
quelques fêtes la France est restée
relativement à l'écart des grands
mouvements de demandes de protection que
ce soit au moment de la crise syrienne
ou au moment de actuellement avec la
crise ukrainienne nous ne sommes pas le
pays qui en avons accueilli le plus
d'ukrainien
deuxièmement nous délivrons finalement
relativement peu de premier titre de
séjour tous les ans par rapport à des
pays de taille similaires avec une
économie de tels de même nature enfin
plutôt que de penser que
l'émigrations croisent de manière
exponentielle au début du 20e siècle
5% de la population mondiale a été
migrante aujourd'hui c'est moins de 3,5
%. enfin l'immigration familiale en
France elle n'est pas open bar il faut
plus de 18 mois de présence en France et
des conditions précises de ressources et
de logement
madame la Première ministre sur ce
gouvernement
sur ce sujet c'est le gouver c'est la
politique du désordre et de l'affichage
des ordres des préfectures
dysfonctionnelles où il est impossible
de prendre rendez-vous des personnes en
situation irrégulière qui deviennent
irrégulières parce qu'elles ne peuvent
pas avoir de documents renouvelés 50% de
la justice administrative des mobilisée
sur ces dysfonctionnements qui coûtent à
l'état et vous aurez vous à nous
annoncer monsieur le Premier monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur un
renouvellement automatique comment cela
va-t-il se passer réellement désordre
lorsque depuis vous êtes monsieur
interviewiste depuis deux ans rien n'est
fait pour régler la question des
personnes qui sont ni expulsables ni
régularisables il faut absolument faire
un examen à 360 degrés de l'ensemble des
situations et pour cela il faut du
personnel désordre lorsque lors d'une
préfecture à l'autre
nous ne se prêtons pas de la même
manière les demandes des examens de
demande d'admission exceptionnelle au
séjour parfois même c'est impossible
désordre lorsque pour le chiffre et
l'affichage monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vous exigez pour des préfets
plus d'aquitf alors qu'ils devraient se
contenter de se concentrer sur ce qui
est faisable en premier lieu sur les
personnes qui représentent réellement un
risque pour l'ordre public et pas
simplement lorsqu'elles sont inscrites
au Tage à vouloir faire du chiffre on ne
fait pas correctement l'essentiel vous
instrumentalisez instrumentaliser les
dublinets pour faire du chiffre ils
reviennent une semaine après et les
personnels de la PAF ils ont perdu
absolument le sens de leur action vous
avez des cras qui sont vous fixez
l'objectif de de
rempli à 90% mais monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur des CRA qui fonctionne ce
sont des craints ou les personnes qui
sont retenues sont des personnes qui
peuvent être éloignées
désordre lorsque vous rappelez le
rapport Stal lorsque vous appelez à
simplifier le droit des étrangers et
nous sommes d'accord avec cela mais
alors pourquoi annoncer un acte
administratif comme une occultéf dès
lors que le frein refuserait une
protection ce serait un acte
administratif qui nous a donné que le
nom si nous respectons la Convention de
Genève des ordres aussi lorsque c'est
défaillances de l'État pèsent sur
l'intégration lorsqu'elle lorsqu'elle
conduisent les personnes à s'appuyer sur
leur communauté plutôt que sur les
services publics et font peser le devoir
d'humanité sur les collectivités locales
et sur les associations monsieur le
ministre j'arrête les choses
désagréables je constate une évolution
entre l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
à l'Assemblée nationale vous aviez
évoqué que vous ne mettrez plus encras
des personnes de moins de 16 ans vous
avez précisé ici que ça s'adopterait à
tous les mineurs je salue cette
évolution en une semaine il faut aussi
saluer que pour la première fois depuis
longtemps
ces questions ne pas se sont pas
exclusivement des questions du ministère
de l'intérieur parce qu'une intégration
réussie elle passe monsieur Eve ça a été
rappelé monsieur le ministre monsieur et
madame la Première ministre par le
travail elle passe par le travail elle
passe par l'école historiquement c'est
ainsi que ça s'est passé en France et on
doit constater que face aux deux plus
grands mouvements actuels au Venezuela
avec la Colombie et l'Ukraine avec
l'Union européenne dans les deux cas les
accueils se font avec une reconnaissance
du statut tout de suite et le droit au
travail tout de suite c'est la meilleure
manière de faire et le droit au travail
c'est la meilleure manière d'éviter
social la meilleure le droit au travail
c'est la meilleure manière de liquider
l'esclavage moderne dont nous sommes
témoins chaque jour dans des actes
essentiels de la vie
et vous avez madame la Première ministre
énormément de marge de manoeuvre pour
faire beaucoup plus que ce que vous avez
fait au cours des dernières années sans
changer la loi d'abord la liste des
métiers d'attention elle n'a bougé
qu'une fois en 2021 depuis 2008
deuxièmement les situations de jeunes
apprentis en situation irrégulière qui
choquent la population et bien elles ne
sont pas mieux résolues aujourd'hui
qu'elles ne l'état il y a quelques
années enfin
frapper les par rapport à ces annonces
qui sont faites quels moyens nouveaux
seront donnés aux préfectures pour
réellement changer la donne le titre de
séjour métier en tension
s'adressera-t-il d'abord à des nouveaux
arrivants a-t-il vocation à ouvrir un
droit au séjour à des personnes déjà
engagées dans ses activités la personne
la persuasion du gouvernement qui refuse
la présomption de salariat pour des
travailleurs des plateformes sera-t-elle
maintenue rendant un faux bulle la
situation de milliers de clandestins qui
aujourd'hui participent à notre économie
mes chers collègues la France est dans
l'espace Schengen c'est un espace de
libre circulation et une commission
d'enquête du Sénat il y a quelques
années à rappeler l'intérêt et l'utilité
de cette espace de libre circulation dès
lors qu'il y avait entre nos pays des
échanges d'information solides et la
confiance et d'autre part une
surveillance sérieuse des frontières
extérieures et nous avons entre 2012 et
réformer l'interopylité des systèmes mis
en place le PNR lancer le projet Ethias
et renforcer le mandat de Frontex
l'Europe sur ces questions n'est pas un
problème c'est une solution chaque État
doit donc respecter le droit européen le
pacte asile migration avocat renforcé
encore la cohérence de cette action et
ce que nous avons constaté l'année
dernière avec ce qui se passait à la
frontière des pays baltes et de la
Pologne avec la Biélorussie souligne
qu'il peut y avoir des nouvelles
arrivées des nouvelles situations
imprévues qui méritent d'être de manière
construite solidaire entre les pays
européens mais cela oblige chaque pays
européen à respecter le droit européen
le droit européen l'Italie elle doit
respecter le droit de la mer mais la
France elle doit le respecter aussi le
droit européen lorsqu'il s'agit de
respecter le fait que en Europe il y a
la libre circulation et on ne peut pas
systématiquement remettre en place des
contrôles aux frontières intérieures de
l'Union la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne la correctement rappelé et il
est important de respecter le droit
européen si on veut elle a rappelé au
Conseil d'État autrichien monsieur le
ministre vous voulez pas l'entendre mais
regardez ce qui se passe avec l'Autriche
la politique de visa monsieur le
ministre que vous avez mis en place en
particulier depuis quelques mois
qu'est-ce que c'est des délais
incroyables des refus arbitraire des
projets de vie détruit voilà aujourd'hui
une politique de visa qui détruit
progressivement les liens historiques
que nous avons avec les pays du Sud de
la Méditerranée ce n'est plus Paris mais
Istanbul Dubaï même parfois Moscou qui
font référence aux yeux de beaucoup et
nous n'avons qu'un enfant qu'à
nous-mêmes et à votre politique dans de
très nombreux pays les communautés se
plaignent de contrats qui ne peuvent
plus être conclus de visite une queue
peuvent plus être faites cela doit
cesser plus de 17000 morts en
Méditerranée au cours des six dernières
années des milliers d'enfants disparus
sur la route des Balkans monsieur le
ministre madame la Première ministre
cela doit cesser la lutte contre les
passeurs n'est pas compatible avec le
financement de structurer opaque où je
trouve tels que les gardes contre les
gardes frontières libyens obtenir des
laissez passer consulaires lorsque cela
est nécessaire ne peut pas se faire dans
un d'une démarche de coup de menton elle
doit se paraisser dans une démarche bien
comprise avec les pays d'origine et de
transit une démarche qui doit donner une
place significative à des politiques de
mobilité légale
enfin l'asile qui depuis notre
révolution est au cœur de notre identité
elle était essentielle cette politique
les personnes qui méritent d'être
protégées
elles viennent après avoir vécu des
chocs terribles elle ne peuvent pas être
en mesure en quelques jours de préparer
leur récit correctement alors monsieur
le ministre que vous annoncez un guichet
français très bien
mais auront-elle le temps de se préparer
deuxièmement vous nous annoncez une
réforme de la CNDA nous refusons le juge
unique systématique nous ne voulons pas
que la chair soit mis en dehors des CNDA
et nous considérons aussi qu'il faut
avancer sur une reconnaissance sur une
reconnaissance européenne des
instructions des demandes d'asile et
cela doit passer par une Cour européenne
du droit d'asile enfin il est essentiel
qu'aucune minute ne soit perdue pour une
personne qui entend demande des îles
pour lui reconnaître le droit au travail
le droit à la formation et le droit à
l'apprentissage de la langue aucune
minute ne doit être perdu pour lui
donner la possibilité d'être autonome le
plus vite possible enfin
il y a encore beaucoup de choses à dire
en particulier sur les questions liées à
l'outre-mer
mais si nous sommes une république il
n'y a qu'un seul territoire sur lequel
il n'y a qu'une seule loi la situation à
Mayotte est très compliquée mais il est
isaacceptable qu'un titre de séjour à
Mayotte ne donne pas le droit de voyager
dans l'Hexagone toutes les larmes qui
sont versées sur Mayotte ne sont qui
pochésie si les étrangers qui sont en
situation régulière à Mayotte ne peuvent
pas tous venir en France s'il le
souhaite
voilà une politique humaine cohérente et
résolue profondément européenne avec ce
type de politique nous pouvons retrouver
la voie de la confiance en nous-mêmes
corriger nos erreurs afin de récupérer
une capacité d'intégrer celles et ceux
qui viennent se réfugier viennent
travailler et étudier en France et il
contribue ensuite à l'édification de
notre pays c'est ainsi que notre pays
s'est construit grâce à des apports à
des diversités étrangères et c'est avec
cette force et avec cette volonté que
nous pouvons continuer si nous avons
confiance en nous si nous avons
confiance dans notre histoire si nous
avons confiance dans nos principes et si
nous avons confiance et nous donnons
confiance à l'Europe je vous remercie
paroles de notre collègue Philippe Van
Carrère pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre messieurs les ministres
l'immigration met en tension la
souveraineté qui fondent l'État et la
citoyenneté qui fondent la nation avec
mes collègues centrices nous souhaitons
présenter nos propositions dans le délai
bref un parti elles seront cursives et
je m'indexus par avance nous ne
partageons pas l'idée suivant laquelle
l'action de l'exécutif serait empêché ou
interdit par l'État droit les deux sont
compatibles aussi nous nous ferons
aucune proposition de nature
constitutionnelle
le premier niveau de solution est
européen la révision du paquet agile est
un échec prollement durable relevons
quelques avancées avec la montée en
puissance de Frontex la création de
l'Agence européenne pour les îles avec
l'objectif d'harmoniser les politiques
en particulier la liste des pays d'issus
nous proposons une reconnaissance
mutuelle des décisions de rejet d'une
demande d'asile afin d'éviter les
migrations dites de rebond si cet
objectif n'est pas atteignable à 27 il
pourrait l'être par une coopération
renforcée madame le Premier ministre à
partir de 9 états ou par des accords
bilatéraux nous souhaitons aussi
l'entrée en vigueur effective en 2023
monsieur musée de l'intérieur du système
entrée-sortie système dit ees enfin
robuste avec la précision qu'en cas de
refus de se soumettre au relevé
d'empreinte l'intéresser se verrait
refuser l'accès au territoire européen
pour revenir en France la première voie
d'immigration et familiale outil du
droit à la vie privée nous faisons deux
propositions portez des 18 à 24 mois le
délai de présence régulière sur le
territoire à partir duquel pourrait être
faite la demande de rapprochement c'est
le délai plafond fixé par les directives
de 2003 la deuxième proposition consiste
à explorer les mesures conditionnelles
visées par la directive de 2003 à savoir
disposer de ressources suffisantes dans
le logement le respect de l'ordre public
il fait pour la personne faisant l'objet
de la demande de rapprochement de se
conformer aux mesures dites
d'intégration chaque mot à son
importance nous pensons en particulier à
la maîtrise préalable de la langue
française au titre du contrat
d'intégration mais je reconnais bien
volontiers que notre collègue François
de Noël buffet eu raison d'évoquer tout
à l'heure la connaissance de la culture
française
si nous mettons à part
les visas étudiants qui ne semblent pas
faire de difficultés la deuxième voie
d'immigration est celle des permis de
séjour votre proposition majeure madame
la Première ministre monsieur les
ministres porte sur un permis de séjour
pour les métiers en tension nous serions
favorables à des permis de séjour pour
des métiers en tension
qualifiés qualifié chacun est conscient
de cette vieille pratique française
tandote a confié les métiers que nos
concitoyens ne souhaitent pas assurer à
bas prix à des étrangers
avec ce système rien ne changera c'est
une trappe à bas salaire assurée ces
métiers ne seront jamais attractifs
financièrement pour nos concitoyens ne
monteront pas en qualification en gamme
ne feront l'objet d'aucun investissement
d'automatisation les basses à l'air
entraînent des problèmes de logement la
nécessité de faire appel aux autres
ressortissants du pays d'origine et nous
sommes repartis vers du communautarisme
mes chers collègues
l'idée d'une main d'oeuvre immigrée
bon marché sans cesse renouveler
et nuisible à notre pays
bien rémunéré renouvelez lorsqu'elle est
nécessaire elle peut être positive
notre proposition serait de vous suivre
madame première ministre monsieur les
ministres à condition que le salaire
versé soit également supérieure à la
moyenne des salaires payés dans notre
pays ou à minima dans la branche
concernée ceci nous semblerait aussi le
gage d'une bonne intégration notre
groupe est aussi favorable à ce qui vous
a été présenté tout à l'heure un débat
annuel ou biennal sur les objectifs en
matière de permis de séjour qui ne
sortent notre sens à aucun obstacle
constitutionnel les Français ont un
effet leur mot à dire et c'est la
responsabilité de la représentation
nationale c'est votre responsabilité
chère collègues de l'exprimer
nous vous suivons aussi sur la
conditionnalité des visas voir de l'aide
au développement sur la demande d'asile
nous serions ouverts à la possibilité
pour le demandeur de travailler sans
attendre un délai de six mois une
manière même si l'objet de la demande
d'asile est différent de jauger si je
peux me permettre sa capacité à
s'intégrer
nous nous suivrons pas du tout
par contre sur une approche que je
qualifierais de communicants le allée
vers monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
pour l'ofra et la CNDA l'offrage fait de
gros progrès dans ces délais de
traitement et nous espérons que
l'objectif de traitement à 60 jours pour
être respecté nous doutons qu'il le
serait si vous commencez à saupoudrer
des agents de l'OFPRA dans les
préfectures les officiers dit de
protection instructeurs sont des
spécialistes cette expertise ne veut pas
être fragmentée et le froid il perdrait
un efficacité de même l'idée d'éclater
la CNDA je module de la territorialiser
pour reprendre vos mots monsieur médises
l'intérieur tout à l'heure nous paraît
tout aussi improductive il est
extrêmement difficile de faire coïncider
dans la vraie vie tel type de dossier
concernant des ressortissants de tel
pays avec la présence de telles
interprète et de tels d'avocats
spécialisés dans le traitement des
ressortissants du dipi la CN
effectivement le maillon faible de la
chaîne et nous sommes de la chaîne de
l'asile et nous sommes très loin de
l'objectif de 5 mois prévu sur un
procédure classique et de 5 semaines en
procédure accélérée vous proposez des
audiences à jujudic et de 6 et du
systématiser les visio audiences nous
sommes réservés sur le premier point
mais très favorable au second qui est à
notre sens la clé d'un traitement dans
les délais raisonnables le Conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas conditionné la
tenue d'une vision audience à l'accord
du demandeur d'asiles et c'est pourtant
ce qui a été obtenu par les avocats dans
un protocole dit d'expérimentation tout
ceci passe à notre sens par une
négociation monsieur le garde des sceaux
avec la profession d'avocat nous sommes
sceptiques à l'idée d'une eau qtf dès le
rejet par le froid vous envoyant mal
qu'elle pourrait être l'efficacité
pratique puisque de toute façon il y
aurait une possibilité de recours et
préférions qu'une décision de rejet par
la CNDA tu vois elle a sorti de plein
droit de l'eau qtf sans avoir besoin de
saisir l'autorité préfectorale sur la
dernière catégorie d'immigration les
régularisations de la circulaire dites
Vans nous rappelons ce qui a déjà été
voté par le Sénat à savoir que la seule
condition d'une résidence de plus de 5
ans en France ne devrait pas être la
seule condition de la régulariser
ce qui a été dit par tous la
simplification du contentieux dans la
dans la logique de accepter de accepter
le président François Noël buffet de
l'excellent un rapport que vous avez
rédigé nous souhaiterions également une
évaluation de la pratique des
certificats d'hébergement fournit au
soutien des visas de long séjour est-ce
qu'il existe une harmonisation des
pratiques dans notre pays quel est le
niveau de contrôle c'est un sujet pour
lequel la participation des
collectivités locales est nécessaire
nous pensons madame la Première ministre
mes chers serait aussi utile cette
participation des collectivités locales
sur le contrat d'intégration républicain
auxquelles nous sommes justement manqués
cette dimension locale pour s'assurer de
la réalité et des résultats sur la
question de l'aide médicale d'État
classique du Sénat nous sommes peut-être
plus réservés que certains de nos
collègues quant à l'idée de la modifier
une nouvelle fois nous pensons que sa
limitation aux soins dit nécessaire et
correcte il n'y a pas de grande
différence entre nécessaire et urgent
elle est aussi complétée par un délai de
carence par contre nous suggérons comme
la formule président du fait et je
voudrais insister là-dessus de regarder
une procédure méconnue celle dite de
l'étranger malade par lequel notre pays
offre une faculté de permis de séjour
avec des accompagnants quand la
possibilité d'apporter des soins
satisfaisants n'existent pas dans le
pays d'origine c'est une exception
française chers collègues aucun autre
pays
très pratique à travers le monde et elle
est aguichée ouvert c'est le terme même
figurant dans le rapport de l'oshi nous
suggérons de conditionner la procédure
d'étrangers malade à une convention
préalable entre le système social
français et le système social du pays
d'origine nous sommes également ouverts
à la proposition bien connue du
président buffet d'une peine
complémentaire qu'il est détaillée en
d'autres temps et monsieur le garde des
sourds on a tracé aussi quelques
éléments aussi je me permettrai de
conclure c'est trop rapide présentation
mes chers collègues vous l'avez compris
pour les sénateurs sont tristes
l'immigration n'a pas vocation à être un
fonds
social qui structure la France reste
solide c'est le sens de notre
proposition madame Premier ministre
monsieur des ministres et de sera demain
de note
merci
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue de président François Patriat
du rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole monsieur le prix
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ce débat
de bonne tenue auquel nous avons
participé était nécessaire nous
remercions le gouvernement de l'avoir
inscrit à l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée
ce débat mes chers collègues il est
l'occasion de regarder en face la
question migratoire et cela en toute
objectivité nous devons tenir un
discours de vérité aux Français un
discours loin des caricatures est loin
des procès d'intention
dire la vérité c'est d'avoir admettre
que oui l'immigration régulière et
régulière est en progression mais non la
France n'est pas confrontée un tsunami
migratoire ce chauffeur ces chiffons
rouge est agité par l'extrême droite
dans le seul but d'attiser les peurs et
la colère et de diviser les Français le
démographe François errant décrit la
situation de notre pays en disant un
nombre d'immigrés en hausse mais pas en
pointe une immigration familiale
contenue un essor important des
étudiants internationaux des
régularisations en nombre limité et je
voudrais à cette époque dire à ceux qui
alimente le fantasme du Grand
remplacement je voudrais le rappeler que
la proportion d'immigrés dans notre pays
avoisine les 10% et nettement inférieur
à la moyenne des pays de l'OCDE loin du
raz-de-marée décrit par les idéologues
xénophobes dire la vérité mais chers
collègues c'est aussi reconnaître que
plusieurs défis restent à relever que ce
soit pour renforcer la maîtrise
migratoire ou pour améliorer l'accueil
des réfugiés et la perception des
Français sur des migrations il y va du
maintien de notre cohésion sociale et de
la préservation de notre pacte
républicain 4 défis majeurs sont devenus
d'abord préserver notre régime d'asile
ensuite renforcer la lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière en progression
continue depuis 20 ans en troisième lieu
améliore les conditions d'accueil des
primo arrivants à commencer par les
conditions d'accès au guichet des
préfectures et enfin peut-être même
surtout faciliter l'intégration des
réfugiés et des étrangers en situation
régulière contrairement à ce que
certains affirment la politique du
gouvernement et de sa majorité est
lisible et cohérente depuis 2017 deux
principes guides notre action à la fois
l'humanité et la fermeté humanité avec
les étrangers nécessitant une protection
fermeté avec ceux qui n'ont pas vocation
à demeurer sur notre territoire c'est la
cohérence qui amène le gouvernement à
maintenir ses diptyque dans le texte que
nous serons bientôt saisies j'ai cru
comprendre madame la Première ministre
et notre groupe le salut sans surprise
les premières propositions ont déjà été
esquissées n'en n'ont pas aussitôt
esquissé que les oppositions sont vite
emparées pour les dénaturer les
caricaturer ou les transformer en contre
vérité j'invite nos collègues
aminorer leurs attaques sur les auqtf
chers collègues ayeux de netteté de
reconnaître que le taux d'exécution des
auqtf n'a jamais dépassé 20% toute
période confondues y compris lorsque
chacun d'entre nous était au pouvoir
aussi l'honnêteté de reconnaître que la
faiblesse du taux d'exécution des occitf
est avant tout lié à la difficulté
d'obtenir de laisser passer consulaires
elle est là la vérité d'ailleurs ce
salut les efforts déployés par la France
pour convaincre les pays d'origine et de
transit de délivrer ces précieux sésame
ce travail de conviction commence à
porter ses fruits j'aurais préféré que
nous nous faisons félicitons ensemble
plutôt que d'entendre certains camper
sur des positions partisanes je déplore
d'autant plus que le gouvernement
propose de s'inspirer du rapport du
président buffet dont j'ai apprécié les
propos tout à l'heure pour améliorer
l'efficacité de la lutte contre
l'immigrations clandestine je déplore
aussi que nos collègues de la majorité
fassent preuve d'autant de dogmatisme
sur le futur titre de séjour des métiers
en tension notre groupe accueille très
positivement cette proposition qui
relève du bon sens non ce nouveau titre
de séjour ne participe pas d'un
soi-disant projet de résignation
nationale et non il n'entraînera pas
d'appel d'air nous en sommes convaincus
cette mesure est équilibrée régularisée
au cas par cas les travailleurs
étrangers déjà présents sur notre
territoire donc déjà intégré dans notre
société et dans le même temps durcir les
sanctions à l'encontre les employeurs
d'étrangers clandestins j'ai entendu
dire ces propositions et le gouvernement
j'ai entendu les propositions au café
tout à l'heure notre collègue et non
buffet les par ailleurs j'avais compris
aussi dans les propos de la première
ministre qu'il y avait déjà répondu
positivement par avance
plutôt que de lancer des procès
d’attention contre cette idée tâchons
plutôt de réfléchir à la manière de les
perfectionner en tout cas c'est la
direction qu'on prendra notre groupe
nous serons par exemple attentifs à ce
que la perte d'un emploi n'entraîne pas
automatiquement la perte de droit de
séjour sur un autre plan nous veillerons
à ce qu'une attention particulière soit
portée aux territoires ultramarins
concernés par les enjeux migratoires les
fêtes parlent d'eux-mêmes ils ont ils
n'ont que trop duré pour prendre
l'exemple du site alisté par notre
collègue à Mayotte 50% de la population
est immigrée les 24000 étrangers en
situation irrégulière ont été reconduits
à la frontière l'an passé 78% de plus
qu'en 2020 je ne vous parle pas ni de la
Guyane ou de la Réunion ou mes collègues
pourraient en parler bien madame
première ministre pour récompter sur les
sénateurs ultramarins du groupe RDPI
pour co-construire le projet de loi du
futur projet de loi ensuite comment ne
pas évoquer les causes profondes de la
crise migratoire vous l'avez dit madame
la Première ministre la maîtrise des
flux migratoires passe par le
développement des pays d'origine là
encore ne cédons ni aux simplisme ni aux
populismes nous tenons souvent cette
musique insidieuse sur laquelle il
vaudrait mieux allouer l'argent du
contribuable seul priorité national
plutôt que le gaspiller dans une aide
inefficace à dépays à des pays noyautés
par la corruption il n'y a rien de plus
faux et de plus caricatural nous ne
sommes pas dupes les relations entre
migration et développement sont
complexes c'est pourquoi l'aide publique
au développement n'a jamais été autant
conçu pour être l'alpha et l'oméga de
notre politique migratoire c'est aussi
pourquoi notre aide doit impérativement
s'accompagner d'une sécurisation des
parcours migratoires à savoir permettre
aux migrants d'effectuer des
allers-retours entre la France et leur
pays d'origine sans craindre de basculer
dans la clandestinité une première étape
a été franchie en 2016 avec la création
du passeport talent et c'est un franc
succès c'est pour cela que nous
soutenons l'idée du gouvernement de
simplifier ce titre de séjour pleurer
annuel et de les tendre professions
médicales enfin les gens terminerai par
là
nous avons assurément les visions très
divergentes sur la politique migratoire
mes chers collègues cependant
accordons-nous sur un point la gestion
des flux migratoires relève de la
souveraineté nationale mais nécessite
dans le même temps un minimum de
coopération européenne la présidence
française du Conseil de l'Union
européenne a obtenu cette année ses
avancées essentielles sur le pacte de
l'asile de la migrate du migration des
efforts restent à fournir pour boucler
les dossiers majeurs à commencer par la
réforme du système de Dublin et la
création d'un nouveau mécanisme de
solidarité la France elle est au
rendez-vous la solidarité quand il se
mobilise aux côtés des Afghans en fuyant
les régimes des talibans des Ukrainiens
fuyant la guerre ou des migrants secouru
en mer il est urgent que les États
membres surmontent leur divergence ne
pense pas nous ne pouvons pas faire
l'économie d'un cadre européen commun
pour la gestion de la migration et de
l'asile sans cela l'Europe pourrait ne
pas résister à ce nouveau
accent migratoire et qui est d'ampleur
comparable qui n'a pas comparable depuis
2015 c'est la raison pour laquelle
madame Premier ministre nous écouterons
vos positions nous étudierons votre
texte de loi et nous apporterons notre
soutien sur les bases que vous avez
évoqué et que je viens de rappeler je
vous remercie
la parole
et maintenant au président Pierre
Laurent
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste
la parole monsieur le président
sur le président madame la Première
ministre messieurs les minis chers
collègues le débat d'aujourd'hui est
censé ouvrir celui que nous aurons début
2023 sur un nouveau texte de loi sur
l'immigration ce sera le 29e en 40 ans
on prélude à ce projet de loi vous avez
publié le 17 novembre une circulaire
mettant gravement en cause le droit
inconditionnel à l'hébergement d'urgence
pour les étrangers les structures
d'accueil et les associations sont vend
debout contre cette circulaire la
discussion commence donc très mal si
elle partait sur de telles bases de
votre ex votre texte de loi pourrait
être un nouvel appel d'air à tous les
débordements tous les fantasmes sur la
subversion migratoire sur les
assimilations immigration délinquance
qui pourrissent le débat public depuis
tant d'années l'hystérie soulevée par
l'arrivée de l'Océane Viking on est le
dernier exemple
pourrions-nous au contraire enfin
débattre sérieusement et sereinement les
migrations sont un enjeu essentiel du
monde et de l'époque actuelle depuis
toujours la France comme d'autres
grandes démocraties s'est construite en
accueillant des migrants pendant
longtemps c'est cela aussi qui a
contribué à faire de la France aux yeux
des peuples du monde la patrie des
droits de l'homme mais rompant avec
cette histoire au fil des lois
régressives nous sommes devenus un des
pays les plus restrictifs d'Europe car
loin des fantasmes c'est cela la réalité
des chiffres nous vivons une grave crise
de l'accueil et un traitement de plus de
plus en plus dégradant des migrants en
France et en Europe un traitement
indigne des droits humains
oui il faut débattre car les causes des
migrations sont multiples guerres
pauvreté extrême violence faites aux
femmes répression des droits humains
catastrophe climatiques jettent des
millions de femmes d'hommes et d'enfants
sur les routes de l'exil la
mondialisation aussi a changé beaucoup
de choses car les habitants de la
planète ou qu'ils vivent considèrent que
les inégalités mondiales et le deux
poids du mesure dans le traitement de la
vie humaine ne sont plus acceptables
agissons-nous contre ces inégalités ces
insécurités mondiales bien au contraire
la politique des pays les plus riches
comme le nôtre ne cesse de les renforcer
citons quelques exemples les opérations
militaires à répétition qui déstabilise
nombre d'États du Sud et du
Proche-Orient les ajustements
structurels et les traités de
libre-échange qui laissent exemples les
services publics de ces pays et
assignent leurs économies à
l'extraversion contre leurs besoins de
développement interne le contrôle
monétaire que nous continuons d'exercer
sur les pays d'Afrique de l'ouest via
Alex franc CFA qui les empêche d'avoir
les moyens d'un financement de leur
développement les internoiements face à
la crise climatique dont le dont
témoigne l'échec de la COP 27 c'est de
tous là dont nous devrions parler si
nous voulons des battre sérieusement des
migrations mais nous n'allons pas en
parler et certains nous rediront avec
des mots nouveaux la France ne peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde mais
à chaque fois que des solutions
concrètes sont mises sur la table pour
traiter les causes réelles de désordre
mondiaux et des conséquences qu'elles
entraînent toutes ces idées sont
balayées d'un revers de main la rivière
des réfugiés fuyant la guerre en Syrie
aurait pu signer une nouvelle prise de
conscience en Europe Angela Merkel avait
déclaré courageusement en 2016 nous y
arriverons ce fut l'échec et le retour
des murs et des barbelés en 2021 après
la prise de Kaboul par les talibans
Emmanuel Macron ne trouvait plus qu'à
s'inquiéter face aux risques des flux
migrat irrégulier l'Europe a tourné le
dos à ses devoirs d'accueil et de
solidarité humaine la présidence
française de l'UE a passé son tour sur
le pactasie et immigration aujourd'hui
le non-respect des clés de répartition
solidaire à l'échelle européenne un
temps évoqué associé à l'absurde de
règlement Dublin génère souffrance et
indignité sur le continent nous vivons
avec la multiplication des camps
d'exilés des violences condamnables aux
frontières des dizaines de milliers de
morts en Méditerranée dans la Manche ou
sur la route des Balkans l'Europe n'a
plus qu'une obsession externaliser le
traitement des migrants et marchander
avec les pays de départ les reconduites
aux frontières plutôt que de considérer
ces états comme des partenaires pour la
coopération et le développement ces
politiques qui n'arrêteront rien tant
les causes des migrations sont profondes
ne font contraire que favoriser les
contours les contournements et les
migrations irrégulières quand il
faudrait au contraire travailler à des
voies légales et sécurisées de migration
et ces voix légales et sécurisées sont
possibles car sinon comment expliquer
que l'Europe puisse accueillir à juste
titre d'ailleurs plusieurs millions
d'Ukrainiens un Afghan fuyant les
talibans une nigériane fuyant un mariage
forcé au l'excision un congolais fuyant
les massacres une famille du Pakistan
fuyant les inondations valent-ils moins
à nos yeux mais de toute de tout cela
nous ne débattrons probablement pas
votre projet pour ce que nous en savons
puisque nous n'avons pas le texte sans
vouloir se concentrer sur deux sujets
présentés comme les deux faces d'une
même pièce la régularisation par le
travail pour les uns l'accélération des
expulsions pour les autres vous nous
demandez donc de nous concentrer sur la
situation de ceux qui sont déjà entrés
sur notre sol donc sur ces deux sujets
quelques remarques sur la question du
travail vous connaissez notre opposition
elle est claire nous sommes pour la
régularisation de tous ceux qui
travaillent
les grèves de son papier ont montré
clairement que des filières entières
emploient ces travailleurs sans les
déclarer au vu et au-dessus de tous il
ne mesure le travail de personnes car
nous peinons aujourd'hui à recruter il
travaille pour notre pays et sont
pourtant maintenus dans une situation de
vulnérard vulnérabilité insupportable
nous ne voulons pas de quota et nous
serons vigilants sur cette affaire de
liste des métiers en tension le
gouvernement serait prêt donc à
accueillir des étrangers mais à une
condition leur utilité pour nous il ne
doit pas s'agir de régulariser des
pratiques d'exploitation patronales il
doit s'agir de régulariser des femmes et
des hommes qui parlent leur travail
peuvent enrichir notre pays et sécuriser
leur vie nous sommes favorables à la
suppression du délai de carence afin de
permettre aux demandeurs d'asile de
travailler des les six premiers mois en
France nous plaidons pour les
travailleurs pour une régularisation de
plein droit non soumise à la durée
précaire des contrats avec un titre de
séjour d'une durée minimale de deux ans
pour permettre à ses salariés de
sécuriser leur vie et leur installation
le ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin
évoque aussi ça a été rappelé ce soir
l'exigence de réussir un test de
français pour l'obtention d'un titre de
séjour pluriannuel évidemment personne
ne peut être contre que les étrangers en
France et qui viennent travailler chez
nous apprennent le français mais nous
serons attentifs là aussi pour que ce ne
soit pas un sujet de discrimination et
d'ailleurs combien de Français aux
origines immigrées ont mis des années
avant de maîtriser notre langue
nationale leur langue d'adoption si au
contraire le titre que vous envisagiez
pour les travailleurs sans papiers ne se
ne couraient que pour la stricte durée
du contrat de travail sa fin vaudrait
alors au qtf et expulsion le cycle
infernal serait perpétré nous nous
inquiétons donc de l'abus de
vulnérabilité découlant de la dépendance
économique et administrateur du
travailleur à l'égard de son employeur
quand on second volet le renforcement
des auqtf que vous présentez faussement
comme une contrepartie à l'autre
d'autres sujets le risque est grand de
prendre de plus en plus de larges avec
le respect du droit vous voulez qu'une
OCC qtf valent expulsion on peut
aisément supposer qu'une telle décision
sera sévèrement éprouvée par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme car
portant atteinte au droit à un recours
effectif garanti par l'article 6 de la
Convention européenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme du point de vue
procédure vous affirmez la volonté de
généraliser le juge unique à la Cour
nationale du droit d'asile vous risquez
de déshumaniser les procédures
administratives avec un risque de rejet
systématique cette
déshumanisation passera aussi par la
généralisation des audiences en vidéo
que vous envisagez c'est éloignement à
sa symbolique car la présence le corps
et ses marques la souffrance ont duré
par l'immigrants n'est pas perceptible
de la même façon dans une procédure
menée en présentiel voilà en quelques
mots mesdames et messieurs les ministres
madame la Première ministre dans quel
état d'esprit et avec quel principe nous
aborderons le débat à venir sur votre
projet de loi je vous remercie si le
président est donné la parole
à Colette mélo notre collègue pour le
groupe Les Indépendants Républiques et
territoires
la parole
monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues faire une
loi et ne pas la faire exécuter c'est
autoriser la chose qu'on veut défendre
la phrase du cardinal de Richelieu
trouve une résonance particulière dans
l'actualité récente autour d'un sigle
dont aucun Français n'avait entendu
parler il y a quelques mois et que tout
ce connaisse aujourd'hui au qtf depuis
des années moins de 20% de ces décisions
sont exécutées il y a dans d'autres pays
des lois qui déterminent qui peut ou ne
peut pas rentrer vivre sur notre
territoire elles ne sont pas respectées
la situation actuelle est
incompréhensible pour les législateurs
que nous sommes pour les Français que
nous représentons et même pour les
étrangers concernés la France est l'une
des premières puissances mondiales elle
doit être en mesure de contrôler ses
frontières depuis longtemps ce n'est
pourtant pas vraiment le cas
cet état de fait ne date pas d'hier les
gouvernements se sont succédés et la
politique migratoire n'a jamais été
jugée satisfaisante dans notre pays ce
n'est pas seulement gênant pour notre
administration c'est dangereux pour nous
institutions en n'étant pas en mesure ou
en ne souhaitant pas donner un cap clair
à cette politique grimmigratoire nous
mettons en danger notre démocratie et la
cohésion de la nation de plus en plus de
peuples européens portent au pouvoir des
populistes et des extrémistes même si ce
n'est pas la seule raison il est
considérations migratoires ont joué un
grand rôle dans le choix des
Britanniques de sortir de l'Union
européenne si l'Allemagne connaît une
montée de l'extrême droite la crise
migratoire de 2015 n'y est pas étrangère
c'est un problème que rencontre
également l'Autriche la Suède ou
l'Italie notre pays ne fait pas
exception
d'élection en élections progresse une
extrême droite auparavant très
minoritaire au Parlement aujourd'hui
elle représente le deuxième groupe de
l'Assemblée nationale certains sont
parfois tentés de copier ces réponses
simplissent en espérant que les Français
préféreront la copie à l'original c'est
un pari hasardeux au succès très peu
probable
entre la porte grand ouverte proposée
par une extrême gauche qui refuse de
voir que notre pays comme aucun pays
d'ailleurs n'a pas les moyens ni
économiques ni politique d'accueillir le
monde entier et la fermeture à double
tour réclamé par l'autre côté de
l'hémicycle devenu marchand d'angoisse
nous concitoyens ont le droit de se voir
proposer une alternative crédible
pour cela il faut d'abord dire
clairement que l'immigration ne doit à
aucun prix se faire au détriment de la
cohésion de notre nation c'est à la
France qu'il revient de décider
d'accueillir ou non des migrants sur son
territoire c'est à nous de fixer les
conditions de cet accueil et nous ne
devons pas accepter que l'immigration
puisse remettre en cause la façon dont
notre société a choisi de vivre dans des
conditions qui doivent rester contrôlées
la France accorde à certains étrangers
l'asile sur son territoire cette
procédure par sa nature mais aussi pour
demeurer soutenables ne peut être
exceptionnelle sans la maîtrise des
frontières qui permet de choisir
d'accueillir au nom des migrants notre
société risque de se déliter il nous
faut au contraire trouver une formule
qui nous permette de tirer au mieux
partie de l'immigration bon nombre de
nos entreprises font face à une pénurie
de pour poursuivre leur activité pour
conserver leurs compétitivité beaucoup
de nos entrepreneurs recourtent à
l'immigration l'exemple britannique
était différent à cet égard en
choisissant son immigration la France
pourrait sélectionner les compétences
dont elle a besoin cela permettra à
notre économie de maintenir son
dynamisme et de pourvoir aux emplois
pour lesquels une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre est constatée dans l'ensemble
de l'Europe par ailleurs le travail
éloigne de nous trois grands mots
l'ennui le vice et le besoin d'isé
Voltaire le travail constitue un effet
l'un des meilleurs facteurs
d'intégration cependant les capacités
professionnelles seules ne seraient
suffire il faut établir clairement les
termes du contrat
pour entrer dans votre société les
immigrants doivent un accepter les
règles en partager les valeurs et un
embrasser la culture ce sont eux qui
souhaitent nous rejoindre et il demeure
libre de choisir où ils veulent aller il
ne s'agit pas là seulement de protéger
notre mode de vie ces conditions sont
également nécessaires à l'intégration
des immigrés par notre société et leur
permettront de devenir ainsi des
citoyens à part entière pour que cela
fonctionne nous devons veiller à ce que
celles et ceux qui seront entrés en
France en respectant ses engagements ne
fasse l'objet d'aucune discrimination si
tous ces prérequis ne sont pas
satisfaits nos concitoyens continuerons
d'avoir le sentiment de subir
l'immigration et les immigrés ne
parviendront pas à se fondre au sein de
notre société
je l'ai déjà dit la problématique
migratoire ne concerne pas seulement la
France
l'Europe dans son entier par son respect
des libertés sont dynamisme économique
fait figure d'Eldorado pour beaucoup de
personnes dans le monde dans tous les
pays de l'Union la population vieillit
la main d'oeuvre se raréfie et dans le
même temps la dépendance de nos aînés
s'accroît de nombreux États membres font
face aux mêmes défis il nous faut donc
trouver ensemble des solutions qui
protègent notre mode de vie à la fois
contre ses propres limites mais aussi
contre les ingérences étrangères à la
suite des chantages Turcs l'Union
européenne a pris conscience de
l'impossibilité de continuer à
sous-traiter à un pays tiers la gestion
de ses frontières extérieures les
Européens doivent assumer leur
responsabilité la montée en puissance
des moyens de l'agence Frontex doit à
cet égard être salué
au début de l'année prochaine le
gouvernement présentera un nouveau texte
sur l'immigration vous avez dit Monsieur
le Ministre vouloir être méchant avec
les méchants et gentil avec les gentils
en d'autres termes vous nous proposez de
choisir un peu mieux qui doit venir ou
rester dans notre pays et qui ne le doit
pas nous y sommes favorables nous ne
feignons pas d'ignorer comme tant
d'autres que l'immigration peut
constituer une menace pour notre société
si elle est incontrôlée cela ne nous
empêche pas d'être pleinement conscient
qu'elle est à bien des égards
nécessaires
regardons la réalité en face nous notons
bien la nécessité de faire évoluer une
législation qui part manque
d'application a perdu beaucoup de sens
nous vous soutiendrons donc dans votre
démarche avec une extrême droite en
progression croissante et une extrême
gauche chaque jour plus irresponsable
nous sommes tous ensemble contraint de
réussir là où nos prédécesseurs échouent
depuis 40 ans je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue je vais donner
maintenant la parole de notre collègue
Maryse Carrère pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues il y a quelques semaines
nous avons pu amorcer cette discussion à
l'occasion de l'examen des crédits de la
mission asile et immigration et la
position du groupe RDSE n'a pas changé
depuis la question de la politique
d'immigration de notre pays compte parmi
les plus difficiles elle est sujette au
fantasmes et aux peurs parfois
irrationnelles à la charge d'une
république modérée d'éviter les écueils
populistes pour aboutir à une solution
équilibrée seulement il existe une autre
dérive qui doit attirer la vigilance du
législateur et donc aussi du
gouvernement celle de faire une loi
juste pour dire qu'on a légiféré je sais
Monsieur le Ministre que vous portez de
vrais ambitions je ne les partage pas
toutes c'est le jeu de la démocratie
seulement le Parlement a déjà adopté en
septembre 2018 la loi portée par Gérard
Collomb pour une immigration maîtrisée
un droit d'asile effectif et une
intégration réussie
c'était il y a quatre ans autrement dit
il n'y a pas si longtemps
quel est le bilan des mesures de ce
texte c'est qu'en est-il des garanties
d'exercices et des activités du droit
d'asile qu'il devait mettre en place
presque 10 articles étaient consacrés au
renforcement de l'efficacité et de la
crédibilité de la lutte contre les
migrations irrégulières qu'en est-il ici
aussi qu'en est-il en particulier de la
mise en oeuvre des mesures d'éloignement
et de modification qui avait été faites
en matière de rétention administrative
et je pense en particulier à
l'allongement à 90 jours de la durée de
la rétention administrative avant de
légiférer à nouveau il serait légitime
que nous puissions analyser la
disposition réduisant de 120 à 90 jours
le délai pour déposer une demande
d'asile à l'échelle de nos départements
le constat n'est pas un amélioration de
l'accueil ni du traitement des dossiers
cette mesure était pourtant destinée à
réduire les délais de réponse aux
situations difficiles
puisque nous devrions bientôt légiférer
cet état des lieux nous permettrait de
savoir où et comment agir efficacement
alors deux aspects principaux
occupent la question de l'immigration
ces derniers mois l'effectivité des
auqtf et la place des travailleurs
irréguliers j'espère néanmoins que
d'autres sujets ne seront pas écartés
par exemple l'amélioration de
l'accompagnement des personnes
étrangères les plus vulnérables celles
victimes de violence ou bien émises
isolée l'accompagnement des familles
également question chère au groupe RDSE
nous allons beaucoup parler des auqtf
c'est normal c'est normal car il y a
manifestement un problème avec ce
dispositif si je maintiens à certains
chiffres la France délivre en moyenne
120 000 au qtf par an mais moins de 10%
sont exécutés les 4 entre ces deux
chiffres montrent bien l'absurdité de ce
rouage administratif particulièrement
pesant tant pour notre nation que pour
ceux qui sont l'objet de ces décisions
quasi aléatoires
tout cela justifie qu'il faille repenser
les différents mécanismes qui entourent
les auqtf afin d'en permettre une
meilleure application c'est à dire plus
efficace et plus humaine
derrière cette idée nous défendrons
l'idée d'une simplification du
contentieux des étrangers à condition
qu'elle leur garantissent un droit
effectif à contester les décisions de
l'administration en plus d'assurer un
meilleur traitement des recours et la
bonne administration de la justice nous
regarderons bien sûr avec vigilance ces
mesures
pourquoi pas généraliser les audiences à
proximité des centres de rétention
administrative ou par moyen audiovisuel
pour éviter les déplacements des retenus
pourquoi pas aussi créer des pôles
territoriaux labellisés pour la gestion
du droit d'Asie mais il ne faut pas que
ces dispositifs soient des contraintes
pour les personnes migrantes et viennent
mettre en difficulté le respect de leurs
droits ensuite nous entendons qu'il
faille trouver le moyen de désengorger
les préfectures en effet il est constaté
que dans de très nombreux cas les
décisions préfectorales sont simples à
annuler devant le juge en raison de
mauvaises appréciations par
l'administration conduisant à de
mauvaises décisions toutefois ce
désengorgement ne pourra consister qu'à
délivrer moins d'eau UTF pour que
chacune soit mieux instruite et ainsi
juridiquement fondée la politique du
chiffre consistant à prononcer
massivement des au qtf se révélant
inefficaces en pratique
d'une autre manière la surpopulation des
centres de rétention administrative
montre également
l'inefficacité de notre politique de
contrôle de l'immigration puisqu'elle ne
permet pas de répondre aux flux qui est
imposé j'espère que nous serons en
mesure d'y apporter des solutions
concrètes et en ce sens dans les aspects
utiles il a été annoncé la possibilité
de mettre en place un titre de séjour
métier en tension notre groupe n'a pas
d'a priori de principe sur une telle
mesure bien au contraire chacun sait
qu'actuellement une part importante de
l'immigration irrégulière travaille sans
être déclaré ce travail illégal permet
d'offrir de la main d'oeuvre dans des
secteurs de métiers en tension je
pourrais citer de nombreux exemples
certains ont la chance d'être mise en
lumière un artisan boulanger pour lequel
un village se mobilise ailleurs un
apprenti bouché cela ont de la chance
mais il y en a des milliers d'autres qui
travaillent par exemple sur les marchés
dans la équation ou les métiers du
bâtiment tout ce travail pour notre pays
leur métier sont souvent essentiels au
quotidien de nos concitoyens
pour autant ils sont dans une situation
irrégulière cette configuration place
ses travailleurs et les employeurs dans
une précarité difficile à admettre un
point stable faible rémunération absence
de tout dispositif de sécurité sociale
alors pourquoi pas un titre de g de
séjour spécial comme vous pourriez le
proposer monsieur le ministre mais à la
seule condition qu'il puisse être
effectif et dans le respect du droit du
travail sans aucune dérogation
autrement dit d'une part nous
n'admetrons pas qu'il soit question
d'offrir aux entreprises une menzoeuvre
à bas coût pour certains métiers boudés
par les résidents nationaux et d'autre
part il faudra impérativement
accompagner le dispositif par des
mécanismes de contrôle et des sanctions
pour les entreprises qui continueraient
de recourir au travail non déclaré bref
vous l'aurez compris ce projet de loi
annoncé suscite de la part des élus du
groupe RDSE des attentes importantes et
nous resterons pleinement mobilisés pour
vous accompagner dans l'examen de ce
texte je vous remercie
solidarité et territoire
merci monsieur le Président
alors la première ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
le débat du jour n'est que le prémices
de l'étude du 29e texte depuis 1980 sur
ce sujet la France ne peut pas
accueillir tout le monde si elle veut
accueillir bien voilà ce que déclarait
le président 2019 pourtant rien dans les
derniers budgets présentés ou des
dernières politiques annoncées nées le
reflet de cette doctrine si mieux
accueillir ces procédés dans le budget
2023 une baisse des crédits octroyés
pour la location des demandeurs d'asile
de plus d'un tiers la discussion visite
d'être compliquée dans le décalage entre
les actes et la parole est grand je
crois au vrai en même temps sur la
politique migratoire aussi disait-il
toujours dans ce même entretien
ce que nous voyons ne me semble être que
la jambe droite de cette politique
migratoire peut-être parce que c'est
celle qui porte réellement ses
convictions comment sinon justifier le
prise ultra présent de la spéc sécurité
comment comprendre qu'un sujet de
société importante depuis cette
considéré comme réellement prise en
charge qu'au travers d'une vision
sécuritaire peut-être aurions-nous aimer
voir et nous pencher sur la création
d'un véritable ministère dédié à la
politique de l'immigration de l'accueil
et de l'intégration
pourquoi ne pas regarder ce débats sous
l'aspect humanitaire de fraternité de
solidarité et même de réalisme ou de
pragmatisme économique sociale et
climatique non je le redis les questions
d'immigration ne peuvent pas se limiter
ni même s’aborder prioritairement via
leur HP sécurité le débat d'aujourd'hui
devrait je l'espère permettre de
recentrer l'immigration un phénomène
normal historique récurrent qui a
participé et participera à la
construction de notre pays un phénomène
démographique complexe tributaire des
guerres des famines conséquences mettant
du changement climatique un phénomène
qui conduira encore plus de mouvements
dans les années à venir entre les
continents et au sein même de l'Europe
en 2017
le candidat Prométhée nous examinerons
les demandes d'asile en moins de 6 mois
recours compris c'est nécessaire pour
accueillir dignement les réfugiés qui
ont droit à la protection de la France
pourtant pour les juridictions
administratives et pour la CNDA les
Costa sont les mêmes une embolisation
totale d'un système mal calibré de
l'accès au préf et à l'OFI pour
l'obtention le cercle nouvellement de
titre de séjour en passant par l'accès
au travail jusqu'à une prise en charge
médicale effective les parcours des
migrants sont trop souvent semés
d'embûches tout le contraire de
profiteur du système maintenant des
milliers de personnes dans la précarité
et que dire de l'ambition portée de
supprimer les protections contre
l'éloignement pour motif d'ordre public
par exemple pour les étrangers résidant
en France depuis plus de 10 ans nous
groupe écologie solidarité territoires
sortent clairement en faveur d'une
meilleure célérité des procédures mais
jamais au départ des droits des
personnes jamais au dépôt des conditions
de travail des agents de votre service
public jugé plus vite certes mais
surtout jugez mieux
vous avancez comme objectif
l'application de 100% des AOC
quelle est cette affichage politique
quel est le chemin pour y arriver quels
sont les dispositifs concrets mis en
place le taux n'a été que de 20% de
manière assez constante ces dernières
décennies nous pensons entre autres que
la multiplication des CRA pour répondre
aux difficultés diplomatiques des
éloignements est un ensemble et que dire
des principes placements CRA pour des
occultés à vieille de 3 ans sans
réévaluation de leur situation
personnelle ou professionnelle il est
clair que cela s'accorde bien avec la
volonté affichée du ministère de
l'Intérieur envers ses étrangers de leur
rendre la vie impossible je pense
aujourd'hui à l'enterrement définitif de
la promesse d'Orléans de 2017 qui avait
vu le président déclaré qu'aucun de
vendeur d'asile de dormir et dehors rien
de ce qui nous a été présenté ne
s’appelle pourtant à ce sujet essentiel
à caler 97% des expulsions des lieux de
vie ne sont pas suivis de mise à l'abri
c'est d'autant plus inacceptable que les
pedes ont couru pour avoir facilité
l'entrée la circulation le séjour
irrégulier d’étranger sera augmenté nos
inquiétudes sont grand à ce sujet pour
les volontaires bénévoles des
associations
en 2022 le président candidat voulait
poursuivre la refonte de l'organisation
de l'asile et du droit au séjour pour
décider beaucoup plus rapidement qui est
éligibles la crise du crédit a montré
que l'Europe que notre pays pouvait
accueillir bien accueillir rapidement
accueillir lorsque la volonté politique
qui est le dérogatoire
ukrainien qui a fait ses preuves de
devrait-il pas tordre à devenir la règle
aller plus vite c'est permettre un
système de rendez-vous plus efficace en
préfecture souvent début du successeur
d'obstacles tel un mur administratif
j'étais déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
les agents sur le terrain ou qu'ils se
trouvent se retrouvent en difficulté
face à une perte de sens de leur mission
et des moyens qui leur sont accordés
cela débouche aussi sur une insécurité
des personnes sans droit sur votre
territoire qui devient de la proie des
réseaux privés de type de séjour les
étrangers sont maintenus dans la
dépendance de l'accompagnement assuré
par les associations ils ne peuvent pas
obtenir de travailler déclaré de
logement ou à bonne accès aux soins nous
accueillons plutôt favorablement les
prémices de la régularisation avancée
des travailleurs exerçants sur notre sol
ou la volonté nouvelle de ne plus
détourner le regard face aux employeurs
peu scrupuleux rien n'est cependant
évoqué pour le parcours vers la
nationalité française
certains de ces travailleurs intégrés
souvent dans des métiers de Première
League pendant la crise du covid en
bénéficier de ce parcours de
reconnaissance vers la nationalité
pourtant rien dans le débat actuel ne
permet de reforer cette accès à la
nationalité pour ces personnes intégrées
qui le souhaitent pour le reste nous
sommes pour le mois circonspect sur la
notion de travailleur des métiers en
tension sur notre sol une sorte de
version de la notion de travailleur
méritants que vous nous présentez
derrière ces annonces il y a un vrai
sujet l'utilité sociale de l'immigré
est-elle une assignation à résidence
comme le disait le président
imaginons une personne accueillie sur
votre territoire car travailleur dans un
secteur en tension ce secteur est
attention pour des raisons bien
particulières difficultés de conditions
de travail précarité de l'emploi salaire
est suffisant ces travailleurs sera-t-il
condamné à rester dans ce secteur pour
rester en France puis en cas de perte
d'emploi
bénéficiera-t-il toujours d'un titre de
séjour cette vision qui pourrait devenir
utilitariste très rapidement du
travailleur étranger interchangeable
nous est particulièrement problématique
le gouvernement aussi présenté un désir
de renforcer les exigences sur la
maîtrise du français certes c'est normal
mais avec quel modalités
d'accompagnement qui seront les
évaluateurs qui seront les formateurs la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
et la priorité du gouvernement l'axe
presque pudique de réflexion de sa
politique migratoire d'entacle la
position de notre groupe est connue de
tous nous pensons au contraire que la
question migratoire ne doit pas ne peut
pas se limiter aux prises du travail ou
de la sécurité les moyens de
l'administration doivent d'abord être
tournés vers la spécialisation de
l'accès au séjour et de l'intégration
la crédibilisation outrancière de
l'étranger contraire à nos valeurs la
modification des procédures judiciaires
administratives sous couvert de
simplification quitte à s'éloigner du
contradictoire ou de la collégialité et
d'autres principes des droits de la
défense n'est pas acceptable et là
backnot list comment ne pas aborder
votre silence assourdissant sur la
problématique des frontières y compris
au sein de l'Union européenne surveillez
plus que secourir nous l'avons bien vu
avec le président Gothard et d'autres de
mes collègues j'ai bien vu la situation
à mon Genève par exemple au-delà de ne
pas se courir beaucoup d'associations
rapportent encore aujourd'hui le manque
d'enregistrement des demandes d'asile
malgré les rappels répétés du Conseil
d'État sur la réalité de ce droit ou est
la réflexion à ce sujet et l'ambition du
gouvernement sur ces refoulements sur
vas-y les gaufres entières notre pays
s'odore essaie d'orgueil d'accueillir et
de sauver nous devons veiller à une
inconnue à une inconditionnalité de la
dignité dans l'accueil à juste titre car
c'est vraiment notre odeur je regrette
que cette odeur cette variable entre
l'Aquarius et l'océan viking
l'acceptabilité des refus doit centrer
dans le respect des procédures et des
personnes chers collègues n'y voyait ni
naïveté ni idéalise plutôt pique mais au
contraire entendait le besoin de bien
accueillir de mieux respecter les
devoirs des personnes arrivant sur notre
sol et notre ambition de travail au
niveau européen
donnez la parole de notre collègue
Esther Benbassa pour la Réunion
administrative des sénateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe
la parole
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
coincé entre une extrême droite
obnubilée par le grand remplacement et
une droite en crise monsieur le ministre
de l'Intérieur et ses amis sont prêts à
occulter les vrais problèmes du pays à
flatter les bases instants encourager le
rejet et la suspicion
notre ministre en orgueille d'accorder
deux fois moins l'asile aux exilés que
l'Allemagne et nous promet que tout
rejet d'asile vaudra obligation de
quitter le territoire donc encore plus
d'aucuns et combien d'entre elles
seront-elles exécutées vous savez que
vous n'aurez jamais les moyens de vos
ambitions cette loi est la 30e depuis
1980 les gouvernements se succèdent la
rengaine ne change pas l'immigration
coûterait un pognon de dingue et les
exilés traverseraient les murs les mers
au périls de leur vie que pour
bénéficier de tous les avantages sociaux
tel l'aide médicale de l'état l'idée est
d'ailleurs partagée par la droite
sénatoriale qui a déjà exprimé le
souhait dans un bel esprit d'humanité de
réduire de 350 millions le budget de
l'Ame dans le PLF 2023
l'étranger à la peau sombre est un
profiteur et un futur délinquant
responsable de tous les mots de la
France
même sous un pont sous une tente
d'infortune même privé d'une couverture
pour passer l'hiver face à lui le bon
référé l'Ukrainien par exemple est reçu
dignement et tant mieux parce que à la
peau claire et chrétien on aura
désormais le migrant économiquement
utile à qui on délivrera uniquement un
titre un titre de séjour temporaire
métier de intention pour le lui retirer
une fois l'attention passée votre
politique d'accueil n'est que sinistre
le plâtrage visant juste à rendre
acceptable ces milliers d'immigrés
destinés à régler notre crise du
recrutement l'État abandonne à leur sort
les étrangers sur son territoire
la situation décras est catastrophique
la situation des mineurs non accompagnée
aussi la france terre d'accueil
un mythe désormais
messieurs les ministres avec cette
politique à temps prévenir les esprits
contre les étrangers et le danger qu'il
représente dans 10 ans y aurait-il
encore une place dans ce pays pour des
Dupont-Moretti ou même pour des Darmanin
j'en doute quel dommage n'est-ce pas
messieurs les ministres
merci
la parole
[Applaudissements]
va maintenant être ministre monsieur
Olivier bèche ministre délégué en charge
du commerce extérieur de l'attractivité
des Français de l'étranger
sur le ministre de la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à l'issue de ce débat
permettez-moi de vous donner quelques
éléments concernant l'aspelier à notre
politique étrangère qui ont été abordés
dans ce débat la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères qui m'a demandé
de la représenter aujourd'hui la
rappeler la semaine dernière devant
l'Assemblée nationale la question
migratoire est aujourd'hui à d'éléments
central dans la conduite de notre
politique étrangère à cet égard trois
principes nous guident en matière
migratoire
attractivité et organisation des
mobilités légales solidarité avec les
plus vulnérables et fermeté face aux
flux irréguliers
la France souhaite porter une vision
équilibrée dans le champ migratoire
d'abord nous sommes attachés au
développement d'une migration légale
bénéfique à notre groupe et nous
veillons tout particulièrement au
renforcement de notre activité à l'égard
des étudiants et des talents nous avons
cette année atteint le chiffre record de
400 000 inscriptions d'étudiants
étrangers en France et la délivrance de
12000 visas dans le cadre des passeports
talents permettez-moi de vous dire
également que notre politique de visa
n'est en rien arbitraire comme j'ai pu
l'entendre elle poursuit en revanche un
objectif d'être activité au service de
l'influence de notre pays
nous portons également avec force et
Constance la défense du droit
international et nous nous honorons
particulièrement d'être dans le monde
l'un des pays les plus engagés en
matière d'asile nous sommes attachés à
la protection des migrants au respect de
leurs droits fondamentaux et comparer
non l'année prochaine à la demande du
Haut-Commissariat au réfugiés le Forum
mondial des réfugiés c'est le même souci
de la protection des migrants qui nous a
conduit à lutter avec force contre les
trafics et la traite des êtres humains
en effet et c'est la contrepartie
naturelle de l'ouverture et de la
générosité de notre pays nous sommes
intransigeants sur le respect de nos
lois et de nos valeurs et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes engagés
à lutter avec la même force contre
l'immigration et régulière pour le
retour la réadmission et la
réintégration dans leur pays d'origine
des migrants irréguliers la France sur
la question de grattoir comme sur bien
d'autres questions recherche donc
l'équilibre
nous poursuivons cet objectif avec nos
partenaires africains la stratégie
migration et développement de la France
couvre plus de 55 pays majoritairement
africains en 2021 les projets engagés
par la France sont élevés à plus de 1,5
milliards d'euros sur la base de
financement conjoint de la France avec
d'autres partenaires principalement
européens nous portons également cette
vision équilibrée dans le cadre européen
et multilatéral si dans cet esprit que
la ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères a participé hier à Bruxelles
au lancement de deux initiatives dites
équipe Europe consacrée à deux routes
migratoires celle de la Méditerranée
centrale et celle de la Méditerranée
occidentale initié par la France
l'Espagne et l'Italie s'initiative
associe les moyens des institutions
européennes et des États membres pour
chacune de ces routes migratoires c'est
environ un milliard d'euros qui a été
investi avec la mise en place
d'instruments qui doivent permettre de
resserrer une opération euro-africaine
globale dans la lutte contre les
filières d'immigration irrégulière dans
l'organisation des retours mais aussi
sur les causes profondes des migrations
irrégulières la protection des migrants
ou encore la migration légale la France
a soutenu fortement l'objectif européen
de consacrer 10% des moyens
d'intervention extérieurs de l'Union
pour des projets liés aux migrations et
cela représente en tout 10 milliards
d'euros sur la période 2021 2027 nous
avons donc un intérêt à nous inscrire
dans cette logique coopérative
indispensable à une meilleure maîtrise
des flux migratoires nous devons
construire ensemble des partenariats
mutuellement bénéfiques pour nous-mêmes
comme pour les pays d'origine c'est la
raison pour laquelle la France a aussi
pris la présidente du Forum mondial sur
la migration et le développement dont le
sommet se tiendra à Paris début 2024
enfin nous réflé avons ensemble en
particulier à l'impact du changement
climatique sur la mobilité humaine dans
une approche transversale et inclusive à
des fins du dialogue et d'anticipation
dans un esprit à la fois de solidarité
et de responsabilité c'est bien cette
équilibre dans la politique migratoire
que nous recherchons également à travers
notre politique étrangère je vous
remercie
notre parole est à monsieur le ministre
du Travail du plein emploi de
l'insertion
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre simplement un mot pour
revenir sur le projet de création d'un
titre de séjour spécifique pour les
métiers en tension puisque monsieur le
sénateur buffet il a évoqué notamment
l'objectif que nous avons avec la
création d'un titre de séjour par la loi
et justement de pouvoir au Parlement
avoir un débat sur les critères d'accès
à ce type de séjour lorsqu'on pense à
une admission exceptionnelle au titre de
la procédure dite valse la circulaire
d'idbals pardonnez-moi il y a des
conditions de présence minimale sur le
territoire d'ancienneté sur le
territoire régulière ou irrégulière des
conditions aussi d'ancienneté dans
l'emploi exercé mais il y a
l'accompagnement obligatoire de chefs
d'entreprise qui s'exposent au risque du
paiement d'une contribution allo-fi avec
le titre que nous proposons le salarié
pourra demander sa régularisation en
pouvant prouver l'ancienneté de son
emploi il nous reste à définir quel est
le bon critère d'ancienneté tout comme
l'ancienneté de sa présence sur le
territoire
des critères ainsi définit par la loi
seront le principal outil de contrôle de
cette de cette de ce nouveau titre pour
éviter ce que vous avez dit craindre
c'est à dire un outil de régularisation
massive ça ne sera pas de la
régularisation massive et les critères
permettront de nous en prévenir ce titre
sera un titre d'un nom renouvelable le
titre n'est pas attaché à un emploi ça
fait quoi un certain nombre de
d'interrogations mais bien l'exercice
d'un emploi dans un secteur en tension
la liste des métiers en tension comptant
plusieurs dizaines de métiers ce qui
permet à une personne qui aurait
régularisé sa situation par un tel titre
et qui perdrait éventuellement son
emploi de retrouver un emploi dans un
des secteurs en tension ou de trouver un
emploi dans un autre secteur et dans ce
cas-là sollicité la délivrance d'un
titre de séjour pour motif économique
pour motif salarié en répondant aux
règles fixées par la loi qui existe et
que nous connaissons je ne partage pas
totalement par contre l'inquiétude ou
l'objectif du sénateur bonne Carrère
concernant la rémunération nous vous
avez évoqué monsieur ordinateur l'idée
de réserver ce titre à des salariés qui
seraient recrutés avec un niveau de
rémunération au moins supérieur à la
moyenne de la branche dans laquelle ils
exercent j'ai deux difficultés la
première c'est que nous parlons là de
régularisation de salarié qui sont
présents sur le territoire et salariés
depuis plusieurs mois et donc avec un
niveau de salaire qui est d'ores et déjà
arrêté et par ailleurs nous savons aussi
l'extrême hétérogénéité des situations
concernées je pense par ailleurs et je
crois que nous pouvons nous retrouver
sur ce point qu'il faut veiller à ce que
ce soit pas une trappe à bas salaire et
que très très certainement le maintien
dans l'illégalité agit comme une trappe
à bas salaire en maintenant une
situation de dépendance du salarié
vis-à-vis de l'employeur qui plus est
quand celui-ci peut s'avérer un délicat
mais je pense que nous aurons l'occasion
dans discuter et de débattre de tout
cela et enfin en écho l'intervention de
madame la sénatrice Carrère il n'y a pas
de volonté là aussi de favoriser des
situations de précarité
de moindre coût pour l'employeur puisque
dès lors qu'il y aurait régularisation
dès lors qu'il y aurait volonté
d'instruire la présence du salarié dans
le temps c'est-à-dire avec une carte de
séjour plus annuelle il y aurait cette
obligation pour les employeurs de
participer à la formation ce qui
implique évidemment qu'ils puissent soit
libérer du temps soit participer sur son
plan de formation à cette formation à
l'apprentissage du français et donc nous
cherchons le bon équilibre pour que ce
soit un titre qui sécurise la situation
des employeurs je n'oublie pas que bien
souvent la situation est créée par le
fait que le contrat a été signé avec un
salarié en situation régulière qui n'a
pas eu le renouvellement de son titre et
l'employeur ne le sait pas
nécessairement et sécuriser le
travailleur avec cette volonté de sortir
celles et ceux qui connaissent les
situations d'exploitation les plus
dramatiques de cette situation de
dépendance
merci monsieur le ministre
le ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
la parole
merci monsieur le Président peut-être
répondre aux différents orateurs sur la
partie qui microscien plus directement
après les explications de monsieur le
ministre du Travail peut-être à monsieur
le Président buffet
vous avez fait de nombreuses
propositions monsieur président
certaines recoupe celles que nous
proposons dans le texte de loi que nous
allons présenter après ces débats au
Conseil d'État je dis au saint-an
Laurent la prairie sera souhaitait que
nous attendions la fin des concertations
politiques je crois que nous voyons nous
sommes vus pardon et nous voyons très
prochainement le groupe d'ailleurs
communiste la semaine nationale mais
également les débats
alinéa avant de transmettre le texte au
Conseil d'État puis enfin de le
présenter en conseil des ministres et
donc au Parlement nous avons donc un
certain nombre de d'avis convergent
des sujets aussi que nous n'avons pas
repris dans le texte après l'arbitrage
du président de la République et de la
première ministre je pense à la question
autour de l'aide médicale d'État ou des
étrangers malades parce que nous
considérons qu'il s'agit là de
disposition que chaque année vous
étudiez dans le cadre du PDF et du plfs
vous le savez plus personne juste dire
peut-être que sur le titre étranger
malade si la question évidemment se pose
et si je ne retiens rien au fait que
seule la France le porte dans ces
conditions les chiffres qui ont été
évoqués la tribune n'ont pas par vous
mais par différents orateurs ne sont pas
tout à fait juste si le permet puisque
nous avons fait une réforme du titre
étranger malade notamment dans la loi
que l'on puisse ensuite dans des
dispositions portées par le PLFSS et le
PLF et s'il y avait bien effectivement
5000 titres qui étaient
étranger malade en 2019
6850 d'ailleurs en 2016 il y en a plus
que 3700 c'est-à-dire une baisse de 45%
par rapport à l'arrivée du président de
la République en 2017 et de 25% par
rapport aux années près covid donc il y
a plus que 37 centimes d'étrangers
malades essentiellement des étrangers
malades aérotiques des personnes qui
sont atteintes du VIH dans des pays qui
ne connaissent pas notamment les
thérapies sur ce sur ce sujet et je veux
dire que ce que nous avons mis en place
et vous le savez monsieur le Président
c'est à dire que lorsque nous expulsions
un étranger notamment un étranger
délinquant
de rétention administratif et qui au
titre de sa maladie parce qu'il peut
avoir une maladie souhaite faire un
appel au titre étranger malade
humanitaire on va dire cela comme ça
désormais un médecin de Luffy
parfaitement indépendant vient constater
évidemment la véracité de la pathologie
et constater si dans le pays d'origine
il a bien la la thérapie pour le faire
et nous le faisons il y a des pays pour
lequel il y a pas de thérapie donc nous
gardons ces personnes conformément à
l'engagement de la France mais dans de
très nombreux cas et de très nombreux
cas notamment de pays d'Afrique il y a
c'est c'est c'était rapide nous
expulsions quand même la personne donc
même si le titre en soit peut-être
évidemment interrogé comme tous les
titres de séjour dans le cadre de ce
projet de loi voilà je pense pas que ce
soit effectivement le débat le même
débat qu'il y a et qu'il y a 5 ans je
reviens pas sur la question de de l'ame
et eu un échange de différence de vue
entre les des sénateurs et il ne sera
pas dans le dans le projet de loi comme
je l'évoquais puisqu'il est dans les
textes financiers peut-être également
sur les exécutions des mesures de
d'éloignement alors c'est sûr que le
débat autour des auqtf devient un peu
totémique je dirais un peu un peu slogan
et ne correspond malheureusement pas
tout à fait à la réalité des choses ce
que compte le ministère de l'Intérieur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
d'ailleurs ce que vous avez mis dans
votre rapport me semble-t-il en 2019 et
2020 c'est le nombre de mesures qui à la
connaissance du ministère de l'Intérieur
ont été exécutés
c'est pas la même chose comme de mesure
qui ont été exécutées je m'explique ce
que nous connaissons nous c'est les
personnes qui ont quitté le territoire
Schengen il est très important de
considérer que cet territor Schengen
puisque quand quelqu'un va de France en
Belgique alors qu'il a le qtf nous ne
savons pas je prends l'exemple de la
ville de Tourcoing il y a 17 points de
passage avec la Belgique il y a pas de
contrôle frontières en Belgique donc
quand les gens qui doivent quitter le
territoire national vont dans un état
Schengen qui n'est pas contrôlé aux
frontières nous ne savons pas lorsque
ces personnes sont partis alors c'est
vrai on y reviendra que le système
entrée sortie Schengen puis Ethias nous
permettra de le savoir demain mais
aujourd'hui nous ne savons pas et
deuxième sujet nous ne comptons que ceux
qui ont soit un départ aidé passer par
l'OFI soit une exécution de locutef
passée par la police aux frontières du
fait de son éloignement effectif parce
qu'il y a eu à laisser passer consulaire
ou parce qu'il y a un passeport qui
permet aux positions frontières de
mettre dans un avion et de raccompagner
dans son pays il y a des tas de gens qui
respectent les règles de la République
et quand ils voient qu'ils ne sont pas
bienvenue sur le de la République alors
qu'ils ont un qtf moi des parts aider ou
au départ sur lequel ils ont fait un
salon de recours sont partis du
territoire national sans jamais passer
par la préfecture et par la police aux
frontières et c'est d'ailleurs non
madame la sénatrice c'est tout à fait
vrai c'est pour ça que la circulaire que
j'ai prise à la lueur de défaire faits
divers sur lequel je reviendrai pas
permet justement de rentrer le nombre de
personnes dans les personnes recherchées
pour justement que passer à l'évolution
française nous connaissons exactement
nos personnes qui sont parties
deuxièmement le nombre de qtf que vous
citer que nous citons tous ou que vous
citez plus particulièrement je parle des
121000 qui ont été répétés ici voilà
2021 ce ne sont pas le nom de mesure
individuelles qui sont prises ce sont
nos mesures tout court il y a des
personnes qui ont plusieurs mesures
individuelles sur elle peuvent des gens
peuvent avoir plusieurs au qtf voir des
qtf et une interdiction de retour sur le
territoire national tout ça ça engendre
les 121 mesures mais quand on compare le
nombre de personnes que nous avons
envoyé dans les pays étrangers et le nom
de mesure qu'on a prises évidemment
vraiment qu'on peut pas tomber à 100%
puisque par nature il y a des personnes
qui ont plusieurs mesures et c'est
parfois jusqu'à 20% des personnes qui
sont dans les fichiers dites des mesures
administratives et puis moi je voudrais
vous citer les chiffres puisque on les
cite tous effectivement ça a été rapide
personne n'avait dépassé 20 %. je dirais
même que l'année 2011-2012 que vous avez
pris monsieur le Président sont
n'étaient pas des mauvaises années à peu
près 85000 mesures prises à cette époque
il y avait je compte en 2011
7970 reconduites et en 2012
6204 conduites si je prends l'exemple de
l'année 2021 il y a eu 124
000 mesures tout confondues c'est-à-dire
y compris des gens qui ont plusieurs
mesures mais on imaginant que ce soit le
chiffre sur lequel on nous correspondons
tous c'est 16984 reconduites c'est à
dire que nous faisons le plus que le
double des reconduites alors qu'il y a
eu moins de doubler de mesure prises
donc on a eu à peu près le même taux
d'exécution monsieur le Président vous
et nous c'est ce que vous avez dit
monsieur le Président le Patriat c'est
vrai que sur le quin du président
Hollande ça s'est beaucoup détérioré si
je prends les mais oui si je prends
l'exemple madame la Gontrie si vous me
le permet ne vous inquiétez pas je vais
vous répondre monsieur sénateur ne
pressez pas la réponse je suis pas sûr
qu'elle va vous plaire
122000 je prends je prends l'exemple des
mesures que qui ont été prises par le
Hollande on était à peu près une cent
mille mesures prises pour 7000 reconnus
aux frontières on va bien que là ça
c'est effectivement beaucoup détérioré
mais je voudrais dire que la meilleure
année de reconduite à la frontière
malgré les difficultés que nous avons
connues en Syrie parce que je ferai pas
la franc de dire que quelqu'un a du
président Sarkozy n'avait pas connu les
difficultés que nous connaissons
totalement en Libye en Syrie on
Afghanistan au Soudan qui a multiplié
évidemment les fronts de difficulté
diplomatique et c'est juste pour
expliquer le contexte malgré les
difficultés diplomatiques et des pays en
guerre que nous connaissons depuis le
début du quinquennat du président
Macron je constate que c'est 2019 quelle
année donc precovide de meilleures
réalisations frontières est-ce que c'est
suffisant la réponse est non ce que quoi
qu'il arrive même 20% ça reste un
cinquième seulement
[Musique]
de sortie par où il est revenu et nous
permettre de lutter contre notamment les
risques terroristes puisque ça a été
lancé je le rappelle sous le quinquennat
précédent le précédent simplement si la
France est le seul à mettre le système
en 13 sorti Schengen ça pas à grand
chose ça va rallonger les délais à nos
frontières et singulièrement dans les
aéroports et dans les ports sans que
aucun pays européen ne nous accompagne
donc nous disons nous que nous on mettra
en place notre réseau Schengen lorsque
tout le monde sera prêt le plus
rapidement et le mieux nous aurions déjà
dû le mettre en place voilà et donc nous
sommes tout à fait d'accord en tout cas
je peux vous assurer pour suivre ce
dossier depuis deux ans visser à
l'intérieur que ce n'est pas la France
qui a soit un manque de développement
informatique soit une volonté de ne pas
le mettre en place simplement nous
n'avons pas le même en train de tous les
pays de l'Union européenne et
l'ouverture de l'espace Schengen récent
qui sera confirmé j'imagine par les
chefs d'État n'améliore pas les choses
et la sortie de nos amis britanniques de
l'espace Schengen alors qu'ils étaient
un des pays qui le souhaitaient quand
ils étaient membres de l'espace Schengen
va poser un certain nombre de
difficultés fortes notamment pour le
port de Douvres et pour notamment non
mais dans l'espace européen pardon en
fait des citoyens de pays tiers et donc
créer sans doute un certain nombre de
difficultés pour eux vers mon homologue
britannique me demandant sans cesse
qu'on puisse reporter évidemment ce cet
entrée ce sont quoi nous sommes pas
favorables dans un premier temps en tout
cas au niveau du ministère de
l'Intérieur
sur l'examen des valeurs de la
République nous sommes d'accord je le
dis aussi au président à buffet nous
avons des dispositions législatives sur
ce point mais on est prêt évidemment
amélioré
en complément de l'examen de langue sur
le refus d'asile vaut qtf il s'agit bien
de deux actes administratifs différents
dans l'occasion d'en reparler avec le
Conseil d'État mais je pense que c'est
pas en allongeant les débats ici qu'on y
arrivera il y a bien sûr à recours je
lisant le garde des sceaux il y a un
recours contre l'acte EQF qui restera
notre volonté c'est qu'il soit
extrêmement lié et extrêmement réduit ce
recours en temps mais qu'il existe
évidemment contre l'acte administratif
qui sera qui sera pris pour Monsieur
pour Monsieur Lecomte alors en fait
monsieur Leconte nous a fait c'est
formidable parce que vous avez fait une
une chronique ou peut-être même un
plaidoirie contre votre propre bilan
parce que vous dites il y a pas assez
d'argent dans les préfectures bah oui
vous êtes tout à fait raison monsieur le
compte 11000 agents que vous avez
supprimé en 5 ans c'est vous qui les
avez supprimés 11000 la Cour des comptes
tout le monde le dit nous sommes le
premier gouvernement non non mais depuis
que je suis ministre en effet sous
l'autorité sous l'autorité de voir fille
de Jean castexte de La Première ministre
quand j'étais miséricorde publique on a
arrêté la suppression de poste de
préfecture et depuis que je suis mise à
l'intérieur depuis Jean Castex et
Isabelle borne on augmente vous n'avez
pas suivi votre programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur en tout cas
vous l'avez voté en première lecture
donc j'en étais fort heureux on augmente
le nombre d'agents dans les préfectures
vous vous avez supprimé 11000 postes
11000 postes n'attendez monsieur le
sénateur je vous ai écouté voilà avec
attention 11000 postes vous avez
supprimé après vous nous dites comme le
coq de Chanteclerc en pensant que vous
faites lever le soleil vous dit bah
alors c'est terrible ça les gens sont
mal reçus en préfecture bah oui parce
qu'il y a moins de personnes et
effectivement si vous n'êtes pas
supprimé tous ces postes lorsque vous
étiez en responsabilité on aurait été on
aurait été bien au courant deuxièmement
les contrôles aux frontières c'est
formidable les contreforts c'est
contraire au droit européen et ce serait
vraiment ce qu'on a le qui a mis en
place ces contrôles frontières
actuellement en 2015 je me rappelais
plus très bien
voilà vous l'avez demandé vous avez
demandé monsieur monsieur monsieur le
sénateur vous avez demandé parfois sur
votre gouvernement et nous sommes huit
pays mais permettez-moi de vous répondre
permettez-moi de vous répondre c'est des
vérités que vous n'écoutez pas vous
devrez rencontrer plus souvent Bernard
Cazeneuve parce que manifestement vous
êtes bien éloigné de la politique qui
défendait lorsque il était en
responsabilité au ministère de
l'Intérieur et je ne cite même pas
Manuel Valls parce que pour vous
j'imagine que ça ça devient quelque
chose de horticaire mais en tout cas les
deux mises à l'intérieur que vous avez
eu défendent exactement ce que nous
défendons et vous aurez plutôt vous
aurez jouir soyez contrôles entretien il
y a 8 pays je rappelle d'ailleurs qu'il
y en a cinq sociaux-démocrates de vos
camarades qui ont mis des contrôles aux
frontières effectivement en Union
Européenne pourquoi n'ont pas pour des
questions migratoires pour des questions
de lutte contre le terrorisme et si nous
avons rétabli les contrôles aux
frontières encore très récemment c'est
justement sur le cas de la teinte aux
trois chrétiens de la basilique de Nice
et c'est évidemment personne à ce
moment-là et c'est pas en ce jour
d'attentat que vous pouvez dire le
contraire ne pourrait retrouver une
autre chose que celle de la maîtrise de
nos frontières sur les visa Balladur et
vous avez tant responsabilité combien de
temps combien de temps vous êtes en
respect mais moi je suis pas contre la
suppression des Isabelle adure toute la
différence entre nous vous pensez vous
pensez vous pensez monsieur le sénateur
que désormais il faut pouvoir permettre
à tous les étrangers qui sont sur l'île
de Mayotte de venir sur le sol
réunionnais sur le sol métropolitain ça
se voit vous n'êtes pas extrêmement
souvent à Mayotte et que vous n'avez pas
dit à vos camarades et lui ici Mahoré
c'est une situation absolument
incroyable qui se passe à Mayotte chacun
en est convaincu et les visa va dur
porte leur nom il date du premier
ministre Balladur ça ne rajeunira
personne j'étais même pas en 6e monsieur
le sénateur vous faisiez je crois déjà
en partie de la politique sur l'asile
vous dites il y a deux types d'asile
différents mais mais il y a deux types
de sujets il a dit d'un côté et il y a
l'immigration de l'autre et qu'en 70%
des demandes d'asile sont négatives
après la CNDA 70% après la CNDA c'est
bien qu'un petit problème d'orientation
quand même monsieur le Center chacun
sait il faut vraiment avoir les yeux
fermés ou être extrêmement naïf pour pas
voir qu'il y a d'une part des gens qui
méritent absolument l'Asie bien
évidemment et d'autre part nombre de
personnes qui utilisent asile pour
rester illégalement sur le territoire de
la République mais chacun le sait
rencontrer les agents de l'OFPRA il vous
le diront tous les jours sans aucune
idéologie et notre travail justement est
embêté du fait que les personnes qui
doivent avoir l'asile mais beaucoup trop
de temps à l'avoir et donc vivre dans
une semaine de paupérisation extrêmement
importante parce que tous ceux qui ne
doivent pas avoir la ville l'utilise
comme une voix d'immigration illégale
c'est c'est la vérité première et
d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens l'ont dit et
c'était mon vrai que je vous renvoie au
débat parlementaire que portait
également le manuel Valls c'est Bernard
cazen d'ailleurs je veux dire à chacun
ici quand vous citez qu'il y a eu 30
textes depuis 1982 je vous rappelle que
vous faites tous ce procès de votre
votre propre passé nous avons présenté
un seul texte en un quinquennat donc
quand il y a eu 30 textes en 40 ans je
comprends la difficulté ça s'explique
d'ailleurs il fait dans la jurisprudence
qui est complexe des engagements
internationaux de la France qu'il faut
rétablir ou des phénomènes migratoires
qui naissent du fait de la
déstabilisation des pays mais c'est pas
en soi un qui contexte en 40 ans puisque
nous avons on a fait un seul en six ans
donc avouer que ce n'est pas un vrai un
vrai argument troisième sujet vous
parliez des irréguliers que nous n'avons
pas comme d'accepte ton trou et que nous
avons pas régularisé j'aurais dû juste
vous donner un chiffre également
monsieur le sénateur en 2012 lorsque
Monsieur Hollande est arrivé au
responsabilités 208 000 irréguliers sur
le territoire national inscrit à la me
on pourrait tout à fait penser on sait
pas combien d'irréguliers en France par
nature on peut penser que l'ame c'est
quand même la chose la moins contestable
puisqu'il faut être irrégulier et on
peut penser que quand même beaucoup
d'irréguliers s'inscrivent à la me
puisque c'est effectivement nécessaire
pour soigner ces étrangers qui peuvent
être malades 315 000 en 2017 donc on a
augmenté de plus de 100 000 irréguliers
inscrits à me soit responsabilité c'est
vrai qu'il a augmenté sous le
quinquennat du président Macron de
315000 à 350 000 c'est une augmentation
malgré le fait qu'en 2020 et 2021 nous
ne pouvions pas reconduire des étrangers
dans leur pays du fait covid il y a pas
d'espace aérien c'était plus compliqué
de le faire cette augmentation elle est
certain importante et elle mérite d'être
régulier monsieur président de la
commission des lois mais enfin n'a rien
à voir avec l'augmentation exponentielle
que vous avez connu et vous n'avez pas à
l'époque fait le courage on portait par
la Premier ministre et par ministre du
Travail de proposer des régularisations
dans une loi puisque vous avez mis en
place la circulaire Valls dont je
rappelle et ça été dit par le ministre
du Travail c'est 30000 régularisations
23000 familiales 7000 au nom du travail
donc ne donne pas des leçons de
régularisation et d'humanité quand vous
avez pas été capable de le faire lorsque
vous étiez en responsabilité je crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit un peu plus
constructif et un peu plus objectif
lorsqu'on parlera de ces sujets monsieur
le sénateur si vous le permettez sur la
question de Madame de Monsieur Laurent
sur le juge unique il s'agit pas
monsieur le rang si je peux me permettre
de généraliser le juge unique à la
sendéa il s'agit de permettre le juge
unique à la CNDA c'est très différent et
de laisser à la CNDA le choix de sa
formation soit elle considère qu'il
s'agit de requérant assez facile soit
pour donner l'asile soit pour le refuser
je prends l'exemple de spécialité pour
lequel on a très peu taux de protection
les Ivoiriens par exemple il se peut que
quelques ivoiriens et l'asile en France
enfin l'immense majorité de ces
Ivoiriens ne les pas ça pose pas de
question de principe ça peut être un
juge unique si il s'agit de question
complexe l'orientation sexuelle les
réfugiés d'une manière d'un pays qui
serait en partition je prends du Soudan
qui est une question extrêmement
complexe ou des questions de
jurisprudence avant que les taliban
arrive type jurisprudence Kaboul qui
avait pris la CNDA on laisse évidemment
le soin à la cour de choisir sa
formation et de siéger soit en collégial
soit en juge unique il s'agit pas pour
le gouvernement de proposer la
généralisation du génie qui essaye de
laisser le choix c'est une demande qui
est formulée en partie elle-même par le
Conseil d'État et pas le rapport qui a
rendu le président la serre donc on peut
avoir des différences évidemment mais je
pense que sur ce point il s'agissait pas
si vous permettez de vous corriger de la
proposition du gouvernement même si j'ai
bien compris que vous aviez pas eu de ne
pas le texte qui n'existe pas encore la
généralisation du du juge du juge unique
de deux derniers points peut-être à
Monsieur benaroche en mercant les autres
intervenants on un débat je crois assez
long et j'ai compris les les
interrogations qui pouvaient être
possible monsieur mélange juste on a
évidemment une difficulté je sais pas où
Monsieur benaroche elle est partie mais
de là où il est il nous entend sans
doute monsieur benaroche représentant de
son groupe politique on peut pas dire
que à Calais il y ait des milliers de
places d'hébergement qui soit supprimés
il y a au contraire des milliers de
place d'hébergement libre à Calais et
dans toute la côte de pâle je lis devant
les élus du secteur j'en suis un ce qui
est vrai c'est que en laissant les
migrants en marge dans des jungles ou
auprès des passeurs on fait le jeu quand
on leur explique qu'il faut pas prendre
les hébergements dans toutes les villes
du Nord-Pas-de-Calais on fait le jeu des
passeurs qui veulent avoir sous la main
pour justement passer de l'autre côté de
la frontière d'ailleurs je salue la
proposition du garde des souples parce
que dans le texte nous n'avons pas dit
il y a le passage de délit en crime pour
les passeurs jusqu'à 20 ans de prison je
pense que c'est une bonne manière aussi
on serait unanime je l'espère pour voter
ce texte en tout cas on ne peut pas dire
qu'à caler l'État ne fait pas son
travail d'hébergement et
d'accompagnement on aurait bien aimé
d'ailleurs beaucoup de personnes nous
accompagnent à aider les personnes à se
faire à se faire héberger je terminerai
pour la question de Monsieur benaroche
sur la le parallèle avec les ukrainiens
et ça a été dit je reviens pas sur les
propos de Madame benassa mais si je
dirais le mot final si la proposition du
Sénat et notamment des groupes de gauche
c'est de faire ce que nous faisons pour
les Ukrainiens pour les demandeurs
d'asile ça va être un petit peu
compliqué pour vous idéologiquement
parce que justement les ukrayants ne
leur donnent pas l'asile le principe que
nous avons utilisé c'est qu'on fait très
vite on leur donne pas l'asile ces trois
ans et il repartent voilà donc si c'est
votre proposition de dire on arrête le
droit d'asile il redonne une protection
temporaire pendant 1 2 3 ans quelque
part je pense que vous serez bien plus à
droite que ceux que vous dénoncez ça me
paraît tout à fait tout à fait contraire
à ce que vous essayez de défendre madame
madame la sénatrice si vous me le
permettez et je vais pas répondre à vos
provocations parce que elles sont elles
sont difficiles et à entendre parce
qu'elles étaient insultantes pour une
partie d'entre elles permettez-moi juste
de répondre à la dernière je ne sais pas
pour Monsieur Dupont-Moretti vous
parliez
en me nommant de mes deux grands-pères
alors vous êtes mal rangés parce que
avec vous il resterait il serait
français ce que vous seriez là
madame la sénatrice j'avais un
grand-père puisque vous parlez de ma
famille qui est né en Algérie du temps
en Algérie était français qui est
sengagé dans l'année coloniale à 14 ans
et qui ne savait ni dire ni écrire la
France il y a apporté énormément et en
1962 il a choisi la France il était
militaire de carrière et c'était un
français de volonté donc oui avec ce
gouvernement les Français de volonté
évidemment on est tout à fait prêt bien
évidemment à construire ces belles
histoires mon deuxième grand-père était
juif maltais né en Tunisie il est venu
dans les années 30 pour travailler dans
les mines et oui il a voulu travailler
dans ensuite rencontrer ma grand-mère et
ainsi me voilà voilà pour votre plus
grand plaisir manifestement il est venu
travailler et oui avec le texte nous
proposons ce grand-père qui viendrait
travailler dans un métier difficile et
bien il aurait été régularisé naturalisé
et ces deux grands-pères ils avaient une
grande qualité parce qu'ils aimaient la
France ils étaient travailleurs il
n'avait pas de casier judiciaire donc
oui je serai toujours là
donner la parole maintenant madame la
Première ministre Madame Elisabeth borne
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs quelques mots en
conclusion de ce débat d'abord pour
remercier les oratrices et les orateurs
qui ont pris la parole ce soir
je note que nous avons des différences
bien sûr c'est le principe même de la
démocratie nous avons aussi sans doute
des malentendus qui restent à lever je
l'ai dit et les ministres également il
n'est pas question de régularisation
massive il n'est pas non plus question
de faire croire que c'est par
l'immigration que nous allons régler les
tensions sur le marché du travail mais
je crois fermement que pour celles et
ceux qui sont sur notre sol depuis
longtemps
participent à la vie économique et
sociale de notre pays depuis longtemps
et sont enfermés dans la précarité nous
devons trouver un chemin vers des
régularisations ciblées en étant
naturellement vigilant à ne pas créer
des appels d'air ou attirer vers le bas
les conditions d'emploi je suis
convaincu que si nous travaillons
ensemble de bonnes foi nous pourrons
trouver des solutions et répondre à des
craintes légitimes
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'ai
noté dans la plupart des interventions
des points de convergence et une volonté
de construire ensemble nous sommes
d'accord collectivement pour agir aux
racines de l'immigration illégale en
travaillant avec les pays d'origine et
de transit et en mettant notre aide au
développement au service de la lutte
contre la pauvreté et pour la transition
écologique
j'ai noté aussi des convergences sur la
question de nos procédures et du respect
de notre droit ça n'est pas une surprise
puisque nous orientations s'inspirent
voire reprennent pour beaucoup de points
les conclusions du rapport du président
buffet enfin je note aussi un consensus
sur la nécessité d'intégrer mieux
notamment par le travail ce que nous
acceptons sur notre sol c'est un enjeu
essentiel là encore nous pourrons
avancer ensemble
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
beaucoup d'entre vous gelaient partagent
notre volonté d'efficacité et
d'équilibre dans les mois qui viennent
et d'abord au Sénat nous examinerons un
projet de loi pour notre politique
migratoire un projet de loi sur lequel
nous pouvons travailler ensemble j'ai
confiance dans notre esprit de
responsabilité collective je vous
remercie merci madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant mes chers collègues
suspendent la séance elle sera reprise à
21h35 pour la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi portant diverses
dispositions d'adaptation au droit de
l'Union européenne dans les domaines de
l'économie de la santé du travail des
transports et de l'agriculture la séance
est suspendue